The president's car is now turning onto Elm Street and it will be only a matter of minutes before he arrives at the trademark.
It appears as though something has happened in the motorcade route.
The JFK files were just released.
The National Archives released thousands of new pages of declassified records related to President John F. Kennedy's assassination.
80,000 pages of documents is a lot to sift through. Can you just tell us who killed Kennedy?
Who should be held culpable?
I don't want to point my finger at anyone in a case like this.
Numerous people running up the hill alongside Elm Street.
Who were the two men on the grassy knoll? Who were they?
This guy's like a radio man. He looks like a Cuban. He's out of place.
And he's sitting right next to the umbrella man.
There's Rip Robertson, photographs of Rip Robertson, who's the field operations commander for the S-Force.
Standing right there in Dilley Plaza, you've got Ed Lansdale.
Photographs of Lansdale sitting right there and his wife identifying him.
The thing that I find to be so special about what we now know is the relationship that Oswald,
had with all these guys.
Back up, man!
Did you shoot the president?
I'm just a patsy.
All of this is a side product of deception, duplicity.
And to think that he was alone, taken completely by surprise by this.
Nonsense. It's nonsense, man. It was all set up by the highest levels.
And they got away with it for 62 years.
Maybe you should interview me.
You know, the JFK files were just released.
Archives, a short time ago, released thousands of new pages of declassified records related to President John F. Kennedy's assassination.
You have 80,000 documents that require a lot of, you know, artificial intelligence overlay,
optical character recognition to make any sense of.
Even then, I think very few people made any sense of them.
I think they left more confused.
There's a great quote by Brett Weinstein where it's like looking through the JFK files is like looking for a needle in the haystack where the needle is missing.
And even President Trump, when he was asked,
point blank, who killed JFK after the file drop, he said, we released the files.
We did a historic thing or whatever.
80,000 pages of documents is a lot to sit through.
Can you just tell us who killed Kennedy?
Well, you know, I was given the task of releasing that because many presidents have gone through it and they haven't released.
And I said, release. We even released Social Security numbers.
I didn't want anything deleted.
They said, sir, what about Social Security?
I said, well, you know, that's true.
I'm not saying it's a bad thing.
I'm just saying that's a good thing.
And nobody's going to give you the answer.
But if you sidestepped the point blank question is who should be held culpable.
And I don't think anybody has a good answer to that.
After that file release.
I'm here with Jeremy Ris, alien scientist.
You've been making epic videos for 20 years on not only UFOs and aliens,
but often the science, the secret science behind all this stuff, along with sprinkling some of your favorite conspiracies.
And it's I can't wait to speak to you, man.
some phone conversations we don't agree on everything no i don't have to we don't have
to that's the point of having conversations and uh i'm excited to have you man thank you for being
here for sure man thanks for having me it's great to finally be here absolutely all right well
there's so many jumping off points there were just these jfk disclosures right like what eighty
thousand how many documents like a whole bunch and then there's you know how many how many things
that didn't write down you know you think like you're planning to murder somebody you don't
write stuff down and keep a blog and a whole bunch of incriminating evidence on yourself so
there's a lot of cool stuff in the documents that have come out so far but you know really
you learn more from talking to long-term assassination researchers who've been way
more i feel like people come out came out of this way more confused than a lot of people did yeah
there's a lot of the the media use it as an opportunity to once again you know hype up this
idea that oh there's nothing in the documents there's nothing new
here
here. This is all just conspiracy theories. You know, the typical Operation Mockingbird mantras
and whatnot. But yeah, really, the JFK research community has cracked this case and they've
cracked it for a number of years. I mean, Jim Mars was one of the first with Crossfire. That
was the book that Oliver Stone's JFK was based on. And that really laid the foundation for a lot of
the investigations that followed. And there's been decades and decades and tons of people have dug
into this from every possible angle. And now it's just come out that, you know, Priscilla
McMillan, who interviewed Lee when he went to Russia and also befriended Marina Oswald and
wrote her autobiography for her. She's a CIA agent. She's a witting CIA asset. And that came
out in one of the things that was revealed in the documents, which shows the level that they went
through to get ahead of the sources and the story and be like, all right, we're going to,
we're going to, we're going to, we're going to, we're going to, we're going to, we're going to,
we're going to put our people in so that anyone getting information about this from the sources
has to go through us basically. So I know you to be, uh, you know, as deep on the topic as
maybe anybody alive and you have a very coherent narrative. So what do you think happened? Who,
who killed JFK? They actually, the shot that was fired from the knoll that killed him was, uh,
was Morales, uh, David Morales. And, and he was called the Mexican. They're kind of different
nicknames. They had,
they were, but he was the crack shot, uh, out of the team, the S force team that had been put
together to kill Fidel Castro. And it was a triangular, uh, a fire team, uh, plan, you know,
to have three gunmen crossfire at a moving target. That was the plan. That was the structure that
they'd set up and that they trained down in Oaxaca, Mexico, you know, uh, at the ranch of,
uh, of Clint Murchison jr. And they trained them up down there to do that, to kill not, not only
Fidel Castro, but Raul Castro and Che Guevara and five other commandantes they had on the list.
Hmm. So this was the 5412 committee, which was run by Nixon under Eisenhower. He's setting up
these sort of covert operations to take out Che Guevara and Castro, but then they get used in
the assassination of JFK. How, how does that occur? Well, well, what happened, what happened
is the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the,
the, the people on the task force, the people that were recruited to be on the, the S force to
kill Castro, uh, in short Castro and Che Guevara and the others that they were rabid anti-communist,
uh, Cubanos that had fled from Cuba in January of 1959 when Batista was overthrown and they all
fled up to Florida and camped out basically in Miami and Tampa, uh, primarily.
And the, the, a lot of them were mafia gunmen that worked for Santos traffic Conti, who was
the Don of the mafia, uh, in Havana and ran the gambling casinos, the houses of prostitution,
but most importantly, the heroin smuggling that was coming in from Southeast Asia,
because that was critical because the, a portion of the profits from the heroin sales that were
going on through the mafia run by Santos traffic Conti and the Gambinos that they were running
the heroin into the United States
and a portion of the profits
that were being skimmed off that sale
were being used to purchase military equipment
and explosives to smuggle to the Kuomintang in China.
Whoa, so this is pre-Iran Contra,
but the same sort of architecture.
Oh yeah, same move.
And that's where they got the idea to keep doing it,
so that they had the whole thing set up
where the portion of the heroin income
was being used to purchase the explosives and weapons.
There was a company set up with offices in Havana
and in Miami that was the Sea Supply Corporation,
they called it.
And on the face of it is the SEA,
oh, it's the Sea Supply Corporation,
some kind of maritime thing.
It was a Southeast Asian supply company
run by Paul Halliwell,
the full-time Central Intelligence Agency employee
running the operation.
So he was getting the money
to the Kuomintang.
He was actually using the money
from the heroin smuggling, a portion of it,
to purchase the weapons and explosives here,
and then they would fly them from here.
And that was that whole Terry and the Pirates thing,
what they call flying the hump,
that they had this whole operation
that a fellow named William D. Pauly
worked for Prentiss Aviation,
and they were providing the airplanes,
and they were smuggling them and flying them into China.
So there was, and, you know,
Clare Booth Luce was involved in it.
Really, Henry Luce's wife.
That's right, and it was, and Dulles was involved.
They were all involved in it.
That's what they called the China Lobby.
That was that whole group that, right from way back,
had figured that they were planning to really turn
the development operations of their economic investments
into Asia.
And Henry Luce then starts Life and Time magazine,
which publishes the Zapruder film, with the Mississippi,
missing frames of the JFK assassination.
That's right.
So that's a very interesting connection as well.
Which, and as you know, I mean,
I know the guy that got the film.
Dick Billings.
Yeah, Dick Billings, and knew all about how they,
they brought it to Rochester and doctored it.
He sat and told me about the whole thing.
That's wild.
So he talks about them doctoring the film,
and taking certain frames out and stuff?
And did the frames involve David Morales
and the other men on the grass?
No, it just, it made it clear that he was being,
he was shot from the front.
Okay.
So you could tell from the thing,
so that they reversed the actual frames of the film.
And then the guy who let out the Zapruder film
is a guy named Charles Douglas Jackson,
who was, basically ran psychological warfare
for the United States.
He was in the psychological strategy board
with Gordon Gray and some of these other guys.
Yeah.
And he let out the Zapruder film in Life magazine,
which he was involved with, but with missing frames.
And so.
And that was a big thing.
The other guy that ran the psychological warfare program
for JM Wave station was George Ioannidis.
And it recently came out that these files proved
that he lied about his involvement with the program.
Because they asked him, who ran the program?
He said, I don't know.
I'll have to look and check for you.
And he never got back.
They never got back to that question, never resolved that.
Well, he's the one that ran the program.
How do you not know who ran the program?
You ran the program.
And he lied about it to Congress in front of,
and the whole entire of America.
So that one came out.
That was it.
That was a huge one.
Ann Slinger, too, that, not Ann Slinger.
Ann Slinger, Angleton, James Jesus Angleton.
And he was running this whole spying program
and the mail intercept program.
And this guy, Reuben Efron, was in charge of that.
And Reuben Efron is in the files.
And they ask him about, do you know Reuben Efron?
And he says, no, that's a lie.
You hired Reuben Efron.
And he ran the spy program for you
that was reading Lee Harvey Oswald's mail
and spying on this dude for years,
because he had a 201 file into the CIA since 1959.
So they were, they have a massive file
on Lee Harvey Oswald following all his actions.
And to think that he was a lone nut
and that we didn't know, we had no idea.
And we were taken completely by surprise by this, nonsense.
It's nonsense, man.
It was all set up by the highest levels
and they got away with it for 60, 62 years.
But it's, I don't want it to be too confusing to everybody.
It's, it's easier kind of having in a chronological structure
to understand how this thing happened,
because it's a, the,
the entire operation was set up way back in 1960.
You know, when Fidel Castro and Che Guevara and the guys
overthrew Batista and drove him out in January of 1959,
Richard Nixon, as the vice president under Eisenhower
and the chair of the 5412 Committee,
the Supervised Covert Operations,
he sent all kinds of communications to Fidel Castro saying,
look, you are fine, you've overthrown Batista, okay,
it's a deal.
What we want to do is make sure you don't have
any diplomatic relations with China or Russia.
You can't have, and he said,
you can't have any kind of relations with them at all.
And Fidel Castro said, screw you.
Who do you think you're talking to here?
You know, and you know, they, they, you know,
waved the old Monroe Doctrine flag at him and said,
which he didn't give a crap about, you know,
and, and so Nixon got really PO'd with him.
And so he then set up this covert operation,
which was called originally Operation 40.
Okay.
And then he recruited, naturally enough,
he recruited a whole bunch of,
a whole bunch of Batista supporters
who supported the fascist authoritarian regime down there
and worked directly with Santos Traficante
because Santos Traficante was the business partner
of Batista and Paul Halliwell
in running the heroin operations.
And it was just a means of covert funding
for the operations to oppose China, to oppose Mao Zedong.
This is amazing.
Yeah.
And they didn't, they didn't want to tell Congress
about it at all because they didn't think
they could muster enough support from Congress
to actually support covert operations against Mao Zedong.
So they did it totally covertly.
The CIA sent up this entire operation
to be supporting Chiang Kai-shek
in the so-called Nationalist Forces.
And the chief of security for, for Chiang Kai-shek
was the head of the Green Gang,
the major heroin operation
in, in China.
No way.
Oh yeah.
Whoa.
Yeah.
That is wild.
Okay, so in 59, 60 timeframe,
you have the 5412 Commission and-
Committee.
Committee, rather.
You have, of which Nixon is ahead
and he's sort of, you know,
running kind of national security.
He partners with mafia dons like Traficante.
Well, actually, actually he avoided that one by one step.
What he did is,
he recruited Howard Hughes.
Howard Hughes, yeah.
He called Howard Hughes
because Howard Hughes was a consultant
to the 5412 Committee.
He would, he had designed the Spruce Goose,
which became the prototype for the C-5A cargo plane
that could fly, you know, major covert operations in
and equipment and stuff.
And he also, he also designed the Golmar Explorer,
that ship that could pick up Russian submarines
off the bottom of the ocean and stuff
if they fell through.
And a couple other extraordinarily sensitive, you know,
and a couple other extraordinarily sensitive, you know,
extraordinarily sensitive programs
that he was working on.
Like what?
Yeah, I can't tell you.
I can't tell you that because of the way I know.
You've said this before to me about Howard Hughes
and then I always go, is it the UFO stuff?
You go, no.
No, no, it wasn't that.
It was-
What else could be so sensitive?
Is it like time travel or something?
No, no, no, no, nothing esoteric like that.
You're a man of the people, Danny.
We need to know.
Yeah.
As evidenced by Tim Dillon's recent
and masterful interview with CNN, Legacy Media,
the media can be a bit problematic.
It's more sensationalist and divided than ever.
They ask leading questions,
brainwashed by their social milieus,
and that's why people are flocking to podcasts.
But podcasts have their own limits.
They're often three hours long.
They're not super efficient.
They aren't always fact-checked.
They're sort of a hybrid of entertainment and news.
So how do I stay informed amidst this backdrop?
I started using my new favorite service, Ground News,
a tool designed for both
skeptics and truth-seekers like many in this community.
Ground News is an app and website created
by a former NASA engineer to tackle a problem we all face,
how distorted the information is that we consume every day
in the modern post-truth era.
Ground News gathers coverage
from over 50,000 sources worldwide,
organizes the stories by topic,
and even breaks down the bias and ownership
behind each perspective so you know what you're getting.
With features like the bias bar and factuality score,
it's easy to see how different outlets frame
and spin the same story.
When you eat certain foods,
you want to see the ingredients list.
This is the same thing, but for content and news.
For example, when I was researching
those mysterious drone sightings in New Jersey in December,
Ground News gave me instant access to over 200 articles,
helping me uncover every angle, from the facts to the spin.
Spoiler alert, I don't think they were just
FAA-approved research drones.
So if you're tired of echo chambers and one-sided narratives,
Ground News is your ultimate tool for staying informed,
and making better decisions.
You can follow your favorite topics and compare coverage
to find the most credible sources.
And for a limited time, you can get the same plan
I use every day for nearly half the price.
Just go to ground.news slash jessemichaels,
Michael's with no A,
or scan this QR code to save 40%
on their unlimited access vantage plan.
Or gift it to someone you know
and have more informed discussions
and hopefully chill out about those drones.
I only promote brands I vet,
and I think you'll find them useful.
Find them just as valuable as I do.
Ground News, the truth is out there,
you just need the right tools to find it.
It's one of those kind of things that,
one of the very rare things that I tend to agree
that it would not be good to tell people about it.
Sure.
You know, it would generate all kinds of damage
and it wouldn't really benefit anybody.
Got it.
It was the bottom line is,
but because of that, he trusted Hughes.
And so he contacts him using the red phone,
the secure phone, which he had
from the 5412 Committee of Communications,
called Howard Hughes, and Traficante told us all this.
This all came directly from Traficante
about how the whole thing happened.
And actually told us the day on which Richard Nixon
called on the phone Howard Hughes
was the day after Nelson Rockefeller withdrew,
from the 1960 Republican presidential primary race.
Whoa.
Against Nixon.
Because as soon as he withdrew,
Nixon knew he was going to be the nominee
for the Republican Party in 1960.
And he was sure he was going to win, right?
So he then took upon himself the authority basically
of the incoming president to contact Hughes
and ask him to put together an assassination team.
Why did Rockefeller step down right then?
I don't quite.
He just withdrew.
He withdrew from the primary race for the.
Was that a coincidence or?
No, no, but what it did is it freed up Nixon
to realize he was going to be the nominee
for the Republican Party.
And so he was therefore confident
he was getting ready to be president.
And so he started exercising the kind of a power
that a president might do.
And so he took onto himself this kind of authority
to actually reach out and have Howard Hughes
set up an assassination team.
Said, but you gotta keep it completely away
from the White House.
So you can't, you just gotta do it yourself.
And so what Howard Hughes did is sent for one of his lawyers
that he had, Bob Mayhew, and had Mayhew,
he assigned Mayhew, said, here's the job.
The president kept, they started referring to him
as the president in their communication.
Traffick County said so.
Oh my God.
They kept referring to him as the president.
To Nixon as the president.
Yeah, they kept referring to him as the president.
Didn't know he was the VP.
No, yeah.
And it said, you know, that he wants this done.
He wants to keep it away from the White House.
And so Bob Mayhew went to see, cause you know,
Howard Hughes was in Las Vegas.
He was hanging out at the, whether it was the,
whether it was the Flamingo or the Sands, one of the two.
But anyway, he was up in the big penthouse there
and it was one of the mob hotels, right?
And so he knew that they were there.
So Bob Mayhew went to see Johnny Roselli,
who was the bag man, you know, for the mafia skim,
the skimming the cash off those casinos to be used, right?
And so his principal, the guy,
in charge of him was Sam Giancana out of Chicago.
And so when Bob Mayhew went to Johnny Roselli and said,
look, youse guys have your own reason
for wanting to get rid of this Castro dude.
You know, he shut down all your casinos,
shut down your whore houses, he said.
And very importantly,
they've cut off the whole heroin supply, okay?
And so that you got your own reasons
for wanting to get rid of him.
So, you know, that Nixon is assuming
that you'll do this for us.
And so, you know, and so, and so, and so, and so, and so.
And so Johnny Roselli said, well, you know,
I don't have the authority to make a decision like that.
We're gonna have to talk to Sam Giancana.
And so they went together, you know,
Johnny Roselli and Bob Mayhew went to Chicago
and met with Sam Giancana and pitched the proposal to him.
And Sam Giancana realized that, you know,
doing a favor like this for the president
was gonna get them a lot of potential goodwill, right?
And so, and keep them, keep the feds off their backs.
So he was agreeing in principle to do it.
He said, but you know, but this isn't up to me.
That's Santos Traficante's territory.
That's down in Havana.
He's the mob boss in Havana.
He's, even though he's up in Tampa now,
cause he left Cuba, he said, so we have to go talk to him.
So they went down, they went down to see him.
Now they were down there about September or so.
This all started around June, around June 7th.
It was when Rockefeller withdrew, June 7th of 1970.
So the, between then, it was now early September.
Johnny Roselli, Bob Mayhew, and Sam Giancana
went down to Florida to, and at the Fontainebleau Hotel,
met with, met with Traficante.
And they had two meetings in which finally Traficante
tells us that, he said, you know,
I agreed in principle to do this.
He said, but I wanted to make sure that, you know,
he said, it wasn't some kind of brain fog.
He said, you know, on the part of Bob Mayhew
or even Howard Hughes, wanted to make certain
that this was coming from the president.
That's what he, that's how he termed it.
He said, and so that they had a third meeting
and a guy, another guy comes to the meeting
at the Fontainebleau Hotel using the nom de guerre Mr. Ed.
And it was Sheffield Edwards, who was the chief of security
of the Central Intelligence Agency under, under Dulles.
Okay.
And under the Eisenhower Bush administration.
But so he comes to the meeting and, and gives them
the green light to go ahead and do this.
And so that's, so what Sam, what Traficante did is
he recruited guys from his people that were from Havana,
these gunmen that he had down there that were enforcers
who had fled with him to, to Florida in January of 59
and had gotten recruited.
Recruited by, by Richard Nixon and the CIA
to run covert operations against Cuba.
Because when, when Fidel Castro just finally thumbed his nose at,
at Nixon and said, you know, screw you.
I'm, I'm going to have relations with anybody I want.
So I'll have diplomatic relations with Russia and China.
You know, therefore, quote, violating the Monroe Doctrine,
you know, of allowing a foreign power to start having influence
inside our hemisphere, you know, or our zone of influence.
And so, so what happened is Richard Nixon had mounted
this covert operation and he'd recruited all of these people
that were Traficante gunmen and, and mobsters basically,
but virulent anti-communists, you know, and were all in the,
in around Miami.
They had the 2506 Brigade.
They had Alpha 66.
There were a bunch of these kind of, it's unfair to call them covens,
but I mean, they were, they were these, these,
these gangs like that were there that were engaged in covert operation.
And so they thought that they were kind of invested with kind of a certain
kind of authority on the part of the federal government because they're paid
by the CIA to do this.
And they set up these, these bases.
They set one up on No Name Key.
They set one up on Swan Island.
They put one in the Everglades.
And then they had two of them at Lake Pontchartrain over in Louisiana,
one on the southern coast of the, of Lake Pontchartrain.
One on the northern coast.
And they set up these,
these paramilitary bases in these rabidly anti-communist pro-Batista,
you know, Traficante gunmen.
A lot of them, you know,
were covert operators working under the auspices of the CIA to run these
covert operations.
So Traficante says, okay,
Nixon wants me to put together this assassination team.
I'm going to take my people who are working with the CIA.
But in a completely different context,
they don't have the capacity just to run covert operations.
What I'm going to do is recruit 15 of them.
I'll hand pick them and we'll put them into this special S force,
they call it.
And that's what they did.
And they would send private planes to go pick them up,
you know,
at these five different paramilitary bases.
They would pick up a couple of the guys at each one and they would fly them
to Fort Huachuca in Arizona and big electronic surveillance operations that
they've got going there.
Fort Huachuca.
And so they bring them there and then they would sign in and then they would
just disappear off the records.
And then they were flown down to Oaxaca,
Mexico,
to the ranch of Clint Murchison,
Jr.
Very wealthy,
uh,
ski on of the,
this,
uh,
oil fortune,
down there,
who his father,
his father owned the Dallas Texans football team,
you know,
Cowboys.
Yeah.
Well,
later Cowboys,
it was,
that's,
that's who they were.
And,
you know,
horse racing and rich people and so on.
And so they had this big ranch down in Oaxaca.
So they set up a triangular fire team base down there to,
to practice shooting a moving target from three different locations to get a
triangular crossfire onto the site,
uh,
onto the target.
Uh,
and they were training them.
And Carl Jenkins was,
uh,
was brought in,
from the CIA to train them on this under ZR rifle.
It was the code name for the program.
But they,
this was a whole separate thing.
And it was not even known to many people at all that this was going on because they were trying to keep it away from the White House.
So that operation is going on.
And the way they funded it was from the skim of money off the casinos.
Uh,
and they would skim the money off the casinos.
They would,
uh,
put the,
the cash into these brand new,
big expensive suitcases and put them in the trunk of brand new Cadillac automobiles.
And they would drive them.
And I know the guy that sold them,
the,
the Cadillacs,
because he had the big dealership there.
Whoa.
In,
in Vegas.
Anyway,
in,
anyway,
then I interviewed him at length about it.
You know,
so that they drive,
they drive the cars,
uh,
through,
New Orleans.
Uh,
and Marcello was there and they did the audit on all the,
all the money to keep track of how much money they were moving.
And then they would repack it and they would drive them into Florida,
deposit it in the Miami National Bank.
Mm-hmm.
Of Meyer Lansky.
Uh,
and then they would wire a portion of the money down into the Banco International,
uh,
down in Mexico City.
Uh,
and they put it into this account by,
uh,
this lawyer by the name of Ogarrio had the account down in the bank.
Uh,
and then they would pay the costs for the whole triangular fire team training base.
Mm-hmm.
Down in,
in Oaxaca.
And,
and that's the,
that's.
So how do you go from this systematic,
uh,
covert operation that ultimately is in support of the resistance in China,
the,
the Guomingtang and the,
you know,
uh,
Chiang Kai-Shek.
How do you go from that?
Um,
and then this plan initially to take out,
you know,
Che Guevara and Castro.
Yeah.
Who are,
you know,
uh,
impinging upon the Monroe Doctrine.
Yes.
To killing JFK.
Well.
Setting president.
What,
what,
what happened is that,
uh,
John F.
Kennedy,
of the state of Massachusetts has received for president of the United States,
303 votes.
Richard M.
Nixon of the state of California has received 219 votes.
This is the first time in 100 years that a candidate for the presidency announced the
result of an election in which he was defeated and announced the victory of his opponent.
All of you work in a cause that is bigger than any man's ambition,
that is,
any man's ambition, greater than any party. It is the cause of freedom, of justice, and
peace for all mankind. And it is in that spirit that I now declare that John F. Kennedy has
been elected President of the United States and Lyndon Johnson, Vice President of the
United States.
And Kennedy comes in, and they brief Kennedy now about the Bay of Pigs plan that they had
going, but they didn't tell him about the assassination team at all.
Hey, guys, I want to tell you about my new favorite piece of apparel. These are called
the Perfect Jeans. They're literally the perfect jeans. I used to wear jeans all the time,
and they're kind of rough and not super stretchy or breathable. These are extremely comfortable.
They work in casual environments. They work in work settings. They come in six different
sizes from 26 inches to 50 inches, and they're all around.
Just
amazing.
For a limited time, our listeners get 15% off your first order, plus free shipping at
theperfectjean.nyc. Again, that's theperfectjean.nyc. Or just Google the Perfect Jeans. Use code
JESSE15 for that 15% off. Again, that's code JESSE15. That's 15% off for new customers
at theperfectjean.nyc. After purchase, they'll ask where you heard about them.
Please support our show and tell them that we sent you. Fuck your khakis, get the perfect jean.
And so they lure him into allowing the invasion to go on, the attempted invasion at the Bay of Pigs.
But he tells them right from the very beginning that he won't provide air cover. He won't provide
any air cover, and he won't provide any kind of U.S. military intervention. You know, they wanted
to be able to land on the beach and basically raise the flag of free Cuba and then ask for U.S.
intervention.
And do it the old-fashioned way. You know, just send in a paramilitary operation. And Kennedy
wouldn't do it. And they said, oh, he said, look, if you're telling me that the people of Cuba want
to rise up against Castro because they're so unhappy with him, if they land on the beach and
they raise the flag of a free Cuba, if the people all rally and toss out Castro, good. If you're
telling me the truth that they're going to do it, you go ahead and do it. And what happened is they
had two or three, you know, B-25s or these old-fashioned U.S. military units that were
down in Nicaragua, actually, that the Somoza, Anastasio Somoza, was supporting them in doing
this. You know, it was this kind of right-wing fascist dude. And so the bottom line is that
they were going to provide their own air cover for this. And what happened is they were in a
different time zone. And so they got there an hour late after the landing. And the guys had been
knifed, whacked already. And so they were in a different time zone. And so they got there an hour
late after the landing. And so they got there an hour late after the landing. And they sank their
ammunition boat and everything, you know. And so they were trapped on the beach. And they all
got arrested. And the whole thing fell through. Wednesday, April 19th, resistance ends. All those
who are not killed are taken prisoner. And then Kennedy took responsibility for it. And this is
where the thing starts. Kennedy took responsibility for it. And the Cubano guys that got all arrested
were upset at him for refusing to do it. And so they got there an hour late after the landing. And
they all got arrested. And the Cubano guys that got all arrested. And the Cubano guys that got all
arrested. And the Cubano guys that got all arrested. And the Cubano guys that got all arrested.
of the president, you know, set ordered in Marines.
There was so much at the time that Curtis LAMAY felt the liberty to do by himself. типа
and not a single.
Like he put a paper in the order list to dramatic act as in the top 10 dei
He put a paper in the order list to dramatic act as in the top 10 dei
of the president.
Apparently, I didn't even know this, during the Cuban Missile Crisis later, obviously, he put us into DEFCON 2 without the president's permission.
He did.
It's crazy.
And launched the U-2, ordered the U-2 to fly over Russia to do the final retargeting, which was, and did it at a low altitude that he knew the Russians would pick it up to send them the signals.
He was trying to goad them into trying to initiate a nuclear war.
You know, so the bottom line is that all that was going on at this time.
And what happened is Kennedy took responsibility for it, of the snafu.
And what he did is he apologized to Khrushchev for having allowed that thing to go down and gave him, gave Khrushchev, Kennedy did, his solemn promise that he would cease and desist from efforts to undermine the government in Cuba.
And he went down to Cuba, went down to Miami at the Orange Bowl, actually, and convened the, you know,
the whole thing.
And he had a whole meeting of all these kind of right-wing Cubano refugees that had fled from there.
And the whole stadium, he apologized to them all in person and said that he gave them his personal guarantee that the free flag of Cuba would be flying over the island by the end of his second term.
And he said that to them.
I can assure you that this flag will be returned to this brigade in a free Havana.
They said, OK, we got you.
And he turned around.
And had lied to Khrushchev and actually converted Operation 40 into Operation Mongoose.
That's all it did.
And set up the big operation on the Miami, University of Miami campus called JM Wave, this great big gigantic airplane set of hangars.
And they had all the operations going on there.
It was a full-scale war operation going on against Cuba.
And so he continued doing that.
And so Khrushchev said, screw you.
And he started moving missiles in.
And so all this was happening all right in that first period from 1961.
He's elected in November of 1960, comes into office in January of 1961.
You know, he does all this apologizing and stuff because it was in April of 61 that the Bay of Pigs thing came down.
And so he apologizes, but he's totally pissed off, you know, at the CIA for bungling this whole operation.
And the days of Allen Dulles were numbered.
And so he waited all the way till the fall in September, October, you know, of 61, and then pushed Dulles out.
But Dulles didn't leave.
He didn't leave Washington.
He had his whole setup over in Georgetown in his big brownstone over there.
And all of the guys from the CIA were going over to meet with him like every day.
He had like a social club.
Wasn't it called the Georgetown?
Do you know what I'm talking about?
Yeah.
Georgetown's a very, we won't get too far, but it's a very interesting place, you know, with every administration.
You've got these very wealthy, social people.
Beautiful, brownstone, kind of old houses.
I've been in a bunch of them.
Yeah.
You know?
Yeah, yeah.
And again, recently, the new administration has got people over there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I remember being in Michael Pillsbury's house.
Which I think was JFK's old house.
Yeah.
In Georgetown.
And just being like, this is amazing.
Yeah.
So cool.
I mean, he's been a kind of lead China expert in every administration since Nixon.
Yeah.
And-
It's a very elite group over there.
Mm-hmm.
So the bottom line is that, so the whole operation shifts over to Operation Mongoose being run
out of JM Wave, and crew chefs are sending the missiles into Cuba.
And then they discover the missiles in there.
The whole Cuban Missile Crisis comes down, right?
Within the past week, unmistakable evidence has established the fact that a series of
offensive missile sites is now in preparation on that imprisoned island.
Goes all the way through into late October, right?
And then this bizarre thing happens with the UFO, right?
That-
And we'll just set that aside for a moment.
Yeah.
Because it's a very kind of comparative new piece of information.
Mm-hmm.
But the bottom line is that by the time they get to October 26th, the night of October
26th, they come to within like two minutes.
Mm-hmm.
This whole thing with General Curtis LeMay trying to instigate an actual nuclear exchange
with Russia, saying that, look, the most-
Mm-hmm.
The most-
They launch nuclear missiles against us, they'll kill maybe 40 million people.
Mm-hmm.
You know, but we'll wipe them all out, and we'll get rid of that entire scourge of communism
coming out of Russia, and then we'll win.
Mm-hmm.
Because we've only lost 40 million people, and we'll have eliminated Russia as a threat.
And that was his whole thinking, right?
Yeah.
And the bottom line is Kennedy is so completely horrified at how close they came to the nuclear
war, this is where it starts now.
Mm-hmm.
And what happened is he reached back up.
He reached back out to Khrushchev, said, okay, you're right, I lied to you.
You know, you're right, we kept on doing the Operation Mongoose, you know, but you shouldn't
have put the missiles in there.
We're going to make a deal, you know, that I'll take the missiles out of Turkey, you
take the missiles out of here.
And he ordered all of those bases, those paramilitary bases, to cease and desist from any further
operations.
But he didn't know about the assassination team.
That had been deployed.
But he ordered this shutting down of all the bases.
And what happens is in December, December of 1962, Frank Sturgis, who is the CIA liaison
to the Cubano guys out on No Name Key, he decides he's going to, you know, he's going to, you know,
even after getting the orders from the president, that they're all to stand down and to discontinue
their operations, he, in complete defiance with the Cubans, launches an assault into
Cuba and sinks a Russian ship.
Whoa.
Which, like, nobody knows about, you know, anymore.
But they sank a Russian ship.
When was this?
It's December of 1962.
Whoa.
Sinks a Russian ship.
Kennedy freaks out over the fact that, you know, he'd already lied to Khrushchev.
Yeah.
And he's going to do it.
He's going to do it.
And he couldn't stand for doing it again.
You know, the whole thing would fall apart.
And so, what he does is he sends in, he and Bobby, who's the attorney general, they send
in six helicopter gunships with U.S. Marshals, because he couldn't trust FBI because of Hoover.
And so, he sends in U.S. Marshals, and they burn out the base at No Name Key and arrest
all those guys, including Sturgeon.
Sturgis and charge them with the violation of the Neutrality Act, mounting military operations
against a country with whom we have diplomatic relations, right? And hold them for almost a week
and then let them go. Okay. But it's kind of shot across the bow. The president's serious,
the AG's in on it, you know, you're not going to do this anymore. Then a second group, the ones in
the Everglades, under the liaison of E. Howard Hunt, start planning another attack into Cuba
in complete defiance of the president, even after what they had done over on No Name Key.
And so Bobby and John send in the same six helicopter gunships and burn them out too,
and arrest them and charge them with the Neutrality Act violations. And the heads of the 2506 Brigade
and Alpha 66 resolve, they're going to kill these guys. They're going to kill John and Bobby,
who are complete traitors that they've lied to.
They came down and promised they were going to support them in overthrowing the government.
Now they're chickening out and they want to kill him. But they know that they can't
get away with it, you know, but they've got the S-Force that's capable of doing something like
that. So they're all kind of, you know, just pawing away like a charging bull wanting to get
at the president and kill him and the Attorney General both, you know, but they can't get away
with this. And so what's going on? And so they're all kind of, you know, they're all kind of, you know,
what happens is Kennedy, turns out, starts secretly, this is the key to this thing,
he starts secretly exchanging letters with Khrushchev through Norman Cousins. This guy is
running 18 different letters back and forth, completely off channel, no State Department
oversight, no CIA coverage, anything. Completely secret communications. And in those letters,
they're deciding that they're both so totally traumatized.
By what happened. And how their military forces can get out of control. And the nuclear weapons
that threat the total annihilation of our whole human species. So they can't let this happen. So
what they do is they start discussing how they're going to order, each of them is going to exercise
their respective executive authority to start ordering the disassembly of the nuclear warheads
in their respective arsenals and destroy them. Not just take them and put them on a shelf somewhere,
you know, and then they're going to start doing it. And so they're going to start doing it. And so
they can just screw them back on another week or so, you know, but destroy them. And they,
they reach this agreement in principle. So he was, JFK was really going for it. He was trying
to denuclearize entirely. Totally going for it. And there's a, there's this book, I think called
Mary's Mosaic. Oh yeah. About, you know, Mary Pynchon. Yeah. Mary Pynchon, who was the wife of
Cord Meyer. Cord Meyer, you know, World War II veteran who I believe came back with a, I think
turned him into a pacifist. And then he sort of got in with the Dulles, Alan Dulles kind of Intel
cabal and became this kind of warmonger who I think later was in charge of Operation Mockingbird. So
like incepting journalism world with, with Intel assets. Yeah. But also was, became this kind of,
kind of bloodthirsty guy. And so his wife, Mary, Mary Pynchon Meyer, she, she was an artist and she
was kind of a little more kind of spiritual. Yeah. And so she was kind of a little more kind of
spiritual hippy dippy and she, LSD stuff. So yeah. So she had an affair with JFK. Even more than
that. I mean, it was, it was a prolonged. Ongoing. Relationship. She, she became in a certain sense,
his actual sort of mistress. And they did LSD together. Yes. And I don't know. Provided by
Tim Leary. That's wild. Provided by Timothy Leary. That's crazy. He provided it to him. I know the
guy that knows him. Of course he did. Did it. Yeah. Okay. Yeah.
Are you still lugging around one of those bulky worn out wallets? You know, I am.
Your posture's not great due to that wallet. Yeah. Are you aware of that? I'm, I'm currently now
more self-aware of my posture. It might be time for an upgrade. Oh, what do you suggest?
My personal suggestion is Ridgewallet. Look at this sleek design. Do you see it? Oh, wow. So sleek.
12 cards plus cash. All in a slim, durable, and stylish package too. You took the words right out
of my mouth. Ridgewallets feature RFID blocking technology. So digital pickpockets won't stand a
chance. Plus with their air tag attachment, you'll never lose your wallet again. Where'd it go? I lost
my wallet. I was just checking my air tag. Easy. Brilliant. Yeah. I was recently in the Colorado
mountains. And if I had lost my wallet, I would have lost my wallet. I would have lost my wallet.
I would have no problem tracking it down. Even in the Rockies. Right now Ridge is having their
once a year anniversary sale. So get up to 40% off at ridge.com slash cosmic. Just head to
ridge.com slash cosmic to see their biggest sale of the year. After you purchase, they will ask
about where you heard about them. Where did they hear about Ridgewallet, Chris? Um, they heard it
here first on American Alchemy. Yeah. Please support our show and tell them.
Our show sent you. Upgrade your wallet. Thank me later. And then I think they do LSD together,
JFK and Mary Meyer. And this is sort of rumor mill stuff. So I'm curious to get your take
after that JFK, because she has this mission of like, I need to like stop these guys, like her,
her husband, Gordon Meyer and all of his associates are going to like blow up the world.
Yeah. And she is like, we need to reign these guys in. And she does LSD with JFK. And then JFK
kind of, he was already more pacifist than them, but he, he becomes more hardcore. Like we really
need to kind of denuclearize. He saw the light, you know, and he went through this metanoia as
we refer to it, this metanoia experience about how incredible this was, you know, and how
extraordinarily outrageous, you know, uh, uh, Curtis LeMay and the joint chiefs have been,
you know, and they'd already proposed to him this operation Northwoods, you know, okay. Cause they
were so desperate wanting to get Castro out of there that they were so dedicated in their mission
to preserve us complete domination and control of the whole Western hemisphere that they viewed this
as an absolute horrible affront to have these guys in Cuba. So they were just desperate to get
the Island overthrown. Uh, and so they kept trying everything to do it. So, so the bottom
line is when Kennedy is, is exchanging these letters and very important thing that people
have recommended that in order to verify that they were both complying with the actual, not only the
disassembly, but the destruction of the nuclear warheads is that they were going to have Pope John
23rd broker the whole deal and oversee the whole process. No way. That's all true. Are you serious?
That's absolutely right. Khrushchev wrote about this in his letters back. They were, yes, they
did it in the letters of going and these letters. Have you seen these letters?
No, but I know what the content of, how do you know from Jesuit headquarters because of, because of
John, John Paul, the 23rd or John, the 23rd was going to be the broker, but he dies. I need to
get in with the Jesuits, Danny. I don't know. Yeah, right. Right. You know, but, but, but he
dies. He dies in early June. So they were working on trying to get this done. So he dies in early
June. And what Kennedy decides is that in order to, to make up for the massive disfunding of
the whole nuclear weapons programs in both countries, that in order to have a massive
economic stimulus to replace that, that the, he wants to, and he proposes to, to Gorbachev that,
uh, or to Khrushchev that, that they have a joint Soviet U S space program that they
completely combine their forces and they, they overcome the whole threat of the, the cold war
and that they joined forces and going into outer space together. And he, on June 5th of 1960,
62 or 63, rather now, uh, uh, of 1963, what he does is he contacts McCone, the new CIA director,
because he'd already forced into retirement Dulles. And he says he wants to get fully
briefed in on the UFO stuff. Now this is, this becomes important because I didn't know when I
found out all that stuff, I didn't know about this other thing. Yeah. The Harold Malmgren stuff.
Yeah, that's right. Yeah. So yeah, he asked to get briefed about,
uh, you know, UFOs and wants to know more. And this is really an important fact. John McCone,
before he became director of CIA, after Dulles departed was also the, uh, lead of the atomic
energy commission. He ran the atomic energy commission. So he definitely would have been
privy to all of the secrets when it came to UFOs, given the nuclear connection. Yes. Yeah. And so
he's asking for that. And then I can, I can give you the little Malmgren piece, which is,
so Malmgren, Harold Malmgren was a presidential advisor for JFK.
He was the youngest of presidential advisors. He was one of McNamara's whiz kids and McNamara's,
you know, secretary of defense at the time. Malmgren is 27 years old and he's in the situation
room around the Cuban missile crisis. And at that same time, the Cuban missile crisis,
McNamara had put him in charge of cost assessments for these new x-ray based missile defense systems.
And so they're doing these tests in the Marshall Islands, specifically at Johnston Atoll,
and you have this, these tests series called, um, you know, uh, Starfish prime tests. And, uh,
one of the tests is, is the Bluegill series. And this is this kind of x-ray projection in the nose
cone of these ICBMs meant to take out incoming nuclear warheads, which we didn't have great
nuclear defense at the time. And so this was this really exciting experimental thing. And the
corporation had a paper on it actually earlier. And so Harold is in charge of doing all the cost
assessing for this.
And, uh, he catches wind that in this test, uh, UFO gets knocked out of the, it comes out of the
plume of the nuclear blast. And he freaks out and he says, well, I need to know about this. And they
used to call them tagalongs at the time because they were so kind of, you know, uh, immune to,
or it was so casual and, uh, you know, cold war kind of intensity was so, uh, you know,
I don't know. It kind of, uh, just made them think it was just, yeah, like normal thing that you have,
uh, you know, a, you know, a, you know, a, you know, a, you know, a, you know, a, you know,
a UFO coming out of the plume. And he said, I need to know, I have like all, I blink at Q
clearances. And, um, they said, no, you don't, you know, this is office of naval intelligence
and the atomic energy commission stuff or whatever. And, um, so they say, okay, you can know, but you
have to, you have to come to, you know, Sandia, uh, complex Kirtland air force base, Sandia,
um, where Lawrence Preston Geis, who's the maternal grandfather of Jeff Bezos can show you
these UFO. You know, they didn't say we're going to show you these UFO,
we'll brief you on it. And then he goes, they show him the UFO pieces. He feels the debris,
he feels this anomalous debris. It speaks to him telepathically, which is remarkable.
Then he insists on getting briefed or he, I don't know, maybe Bissell reaches out to him,
but Richard Bissell, who was number two at went on to become number two at the CIA. But at the
time he was deputy director of plans at the CIA. And he was known as the mayor of area 51
goes in and briefs him on quote unquote, other world technologies.
And all of these kind of past crash retrievals, including magenta of 1933. And so Malmgren knows
about this stuff. And then JFK, I think a couple of weeks later, a few weeks later ends up at Los
Alamos getting briefs, getting briefs. Yeah. So it's like, is that a coincidence? Probably not.
Well, what it is is that then Kennedy realizes that if, if he can give this information to
Khrushchev,
that'll seal the deal that Khrushchev will know that he's completely, he's dropping this kind of
nationalistic competitive thing with, with Russia, uh, in that they can have a genuine joint space
program. And of course they need to know about what this extraterrestrial dimension is if they're
going to be venturing out into space together. And so he, so, but what happens is when he demands
the briefing from McCone, the Bissell and the other guys tell, uh, tell Dulles about it. Yeah.
Because Bissell in, in, in Angleton and the other guys kept going over to see Dulles all the time. Yeah.
In the Brownstone over in Georgetown, because he never left town. He just stayed right there
because the fact of the matter is, is that the reason he'd been appointed to be the first
civilian director of the CIA is the fact that he was legal counsel for Brown Brothers Harriman.
This is Dulles.
That's Dulles, Alan Dulles. And that's where the China lobby is. That's the group of people that
had decided long ago that what they would do.
Is secretly fund the rise of Hitler in Germany, uh, after world war one.
Through the union bank.
To, to, to the union bank and all that stuff that they set up to have them be raised up to be the
bulwark against Bolshevism in Europe. And since the, the investors at Brown Brothers Harriman,
these two dozen.
And that was the initial feeder for the CIA came out of the Brown Brothers Harriman.
That's right. It was, it was Robert Lovett who actually wrote the initial memo to Truman
saying, we've got to, we've got to, we've got to, we've got to, we've got to, we've got to,
we've got to re institute a, a major agency like the OSS. We've got to have it in peacetime.
Uh, and it came from Robert Lovett, senior partner at Brown Brothers Harriman.
And so that, that whole group was where it was the seat of the China lobby who saw the future of
investment, you know, capital investment in the Asian markets.
Cause they already owned a controlling stock interest in most of the war industry in Germany,
which they'd extracted through the Versailles treaty agreement long involved in.
The process they did it. But the bottom line is that when it, at the end of world war one,
at the end of world war one, uh, when the treaty of Versailles was being signed, Robert Lansing,
who was the secretary of state under Wilson, Dulles, his uncle was the uncle of Allen and John
Foster Dulles. He had married the eldest daughter of John W.
Foster, who was the maternal grandfather for both Allen in, in, in.
And John, uh, that, uh, uh, John Foster.
So there was John W.
Foster was the, the guy, and he was an arch imperialist.
He's the guy that overthrew under his, when he was secretary of state, he overthrew the islands of Hawaii and started
taking Guam and that whole thing, focusing on moving into Asia.
That was the whole idea of that.
And so that what they did in the Versailles treaty, he got Robert Lansing, who was the.
Yeah.
The son-in-law of John W.
Foster had, had Robert Lansing, his son-in-law bring his two grandsons, John Foster, Dulles,
and Allen Dulles with him to the Versailles treaty.
Mm-hmm and actually as lawyers at Sullivan and Cromwell mm-hmm that to draft into the,
into the Versailles treaty agreement, the war reparations requirements.
Whoa.
That Germany had to, had to pay war reparations for all the damage they'd inflicted on other
industries.
So that made them dependent on the union bank.
Well, well, what happened.
What happened, what happened was this is even pre-union bank.
This is in 1918.
Mm-hmm and so what they did is they, they said, look, that, uh, you're gonna have to pay these
war reparations.
They impose that, that financial obligation on them, but they didn't have the money to pay them.
Mm-hmm and so what happened is the investors in Brown Brothers Harriman mm-hmm these 20,
24, you know, robber baron families, you know, the Rockefellers and, and, and, and Harriman
railway people and Carnegie and Carnegie and all of these guys, yeah, melons, all of them were there.
Mm-hmm uh, and they saw their future is going, uh, westward into Asia mm-hmm because what they
could do is they could secure control over Europe through Germany mm-hmm uh, and, and what they
would do is they would loan the money to Germany to pay the war reparations and they would take
as security for their loans, the controlling stock interest in like a corrupt ball bearing
factory and, and IG Farbin and all these other major war industries making the explosives and
chemicals.
Mm-hmm.
They would, they would have to pay for the war reparations.
is they additionally loaned additional money to germany to rebuild their war machine so that they
could be the bulwark against bolshevism because at the very end of the of the the first world war
in october of 1917 the bolsheviks had overthrown czar nicholas ii and overthrown him and withdrawn
them from from world war one and so what happened is this this this seat of kind of a socialist
alternative to the kind of investment ideas that were housed at brown brothers airmen that they
viewed them as this terrible adversary so what they did is they leaned in on robert lansing who
was the secretary of state and sent a foreign military expedition into russia that almost
nobody knows about it now the full-scale u.s financed u.s military foreign expeditionary force
into russia to try in 1918 to try to crush the bolshevik revolution
well really and they recruited the white russians all those kind of czarist russians that were in
st petersburg that whole crowd was dallas involved that that dallas dallas was involved with germany
uh he was he was pointed to be the legal counsel for germany uh as well as the legal counsel for
brown brothers harriman so he was he was negotiating both sides of these these financial
agreements so that they they had them owning he was the legal counsel for brown brothers
harriman but for germany as well yes he was appointed by robert lansing his uncle to be the
legal counsel for germany as well so that he was on both sides of the negotiations he was counseling
germany to accept these loans well you know and and to rebuild their their war industry uh and he
he ended up being the basically almost the legal governor general you know working for the german
government uh and so that that that's what he did he choreographed that entire thing
and so
what happened is they got that all set up in 18 1918 1919 yeah then they then robert lansing sent
the foreign military expeditionary force into russia uh to try to crush the the bolshevik
revolution in the cradle hey everyone jesse here let's talk about something a lot of us quietly
deal with hair loss this is something that messes with your confidence more than you'd expect okay
you might be wondering jesse you clearly don't suffer from this it's true the biggest issue i've
faced is hat hair i actually have very thick hair but one of my good friends deals with hair loss
so when iris store sent me their iris store elite i gifted it to him and i've been amazed at the
results it gave him the first thing that stood out to him is it's comfortable and easy to use
you just pop it on while reading or working and it does its thing this isn't some gimmick
it uses 300 lasers and 200 leds to deliver clinically backed red light therapy straight
to the scalp this is the best way to stimulate hair growth over the past few years i've been
using iris store elite for the past few weeks i've seen noticeable improvement with my friend he says
that his hair feels thicker and healthier and it's improved his overall confidence in life
the iris store elite uses triple wavelength technology and lumitec red light therapy it's
engineered for deeper penetration and broader coverage that means more stimulation to hair
follicles and better faster results and look if it doesn't work for you they offer a 12 month money
back guarantee i've never heard of a money-back guarantee that lasts that long try it consistently
and you'll be happy they get you your money back of course the restocking fee applies that made it
a no-brainer for my friend so give yourself the gift of hair confidence this spring for a limited
time only our listeners get a huge discount on iris store elite when you use code jesse j-e-s-s-e
at irisstore.com head over to irisstore.com and use code jesse j-e-s-s-e for our show's
exclusive discounts on the iris store elite please support our show and tell them we love you
sent you hair loss is frustrating you don't have to fight it alone thanks to iris store but let's
let's get back to okay so 63. so so he's aware he's aware of ufos and trying to do some joint
space program with khrushchev around that yes he is trying to defang the american nuclear arsenal
but also have also the russians soviets yeah nuclear eyes and mutual disarmament yes and uh
he is trying to take the country back the u.s back from the china military agreed china agreed that
pursue any interest nuclear program at all do we have records of that yes oh yeah really oh yes
where are the records of that that uh there's they can dig them out because they they he reached
out they reached out to china china only had like he reached out to mal they had a real early uh
interest in kind of trying to deal with the nuclear weapons issue but they hadn't really
mounted a program and and he agreed to forestall the entire thing really mm-hmm
at that point at that point in between basically january of of 1963 and june of 1963 at least prior
to when when john the 23rd died that that was still kind of a totally viable operation that
they were planning to do uh and then when when john the 23rd died i think uh kennedy leaned
forward into it to try to to try to make sure that the thing kept on going and so he decided he was
going to take the information for khrushchev and give it to him as a further sign of good faith
so that they could not only uh have a complete open and honest relationship
by putting some skin in the game by coughing up the information we had about this
but also prepare for the who they were going to be encountering you know out in an extraterrestrial
civilization you know and what happened is uh uh on june 5th when he asked for it
it's almost certain it was bissell you know found out about it you know and told dallas
and so dallas and the guy started really wait they can't allow the nuclear missiles to be
disassembled because they have to have them to deal with china you know because china had
demonstrated already in the career in korea that they could put a billion men in uniform and just
melt your bear gun barrels down by just pouring them on you like they did up at uh in chan in
at the reservoir you know that that's what they did they just sent in like a billion guys you
know and just stormed them uh and so they realized that they could not take on china uh in the future
in a conditional land war so they needed the nuclear weapons that's why macarthur kept saying
what we got to do is show them bomb them you know that whole thing that fall out with truman
so so the bottom line is that china lobby freaked out about potentially losing their nuclear option
against china so that can't be that we can't allow that to happen and we can't wait a year
for the elections you know i mean you know they can probably figure out how to get rid of him in
the election you know uh but they couldn't wait the year because he would order start ordering
the disassembly and so what happened is that uh when he when on that june 5th that uh he ended up
issuing the uh the the demand for the he did the
same thing the same day he did this weird thing because i've never been quite figure out yet about
the printing these uh these silver certificates he did that on june 5th too he did a whole bunch
of these things i guess i met oliver stone once and he connects the printing of the silver
certificates with jfk's assassination like that was somehow undermining of well he was he was doing
a lot of radical things right there yeah because i think that what happened was when when john 23 died
he was hoping to to bring
john 23 in and kind of catholic support for what he was doing uh the ethics of what he was doing
the whole speech at george washington university and all that stuff you know he was going through
this real metanoia at that time you know and but the the act of disassembling and destroying
the nuclear warheads was viewed by dallas and the guys as a as an act of treason you know uh
And not only that, but it was eliminating their ability to actually quell China, you know, and to be able to have access to the market, the Asian market.
So what he did is just green-lighted the S-Force.
So this is this kind of sleeper cell, select group of traficante Cuban exiles who are these kind of killer assassins that were originally commissioned to take out Che Guevara and Castro.
And he re-operationalizes them to take out JFK.
All he had to do was just get up off their neck.
So who were the three, who were the two men on the grassy knoll?
Who were they?
Well, we know that Morales was the shooter because he was the guy.
We know that Rip Robertson was there.
Were they the two men on the grassy knoll?
Or was Morales on the grassy knoll?
Morales was on the grassy knoll.
Okay.
So he took the shot from the grassy knoll.
He took the shot from the grassy knoll.
Wow.
That was great.
That was he.
Wow.
The thing that I find to be, in a certain sense, so special about what we now know that actually happened is the peculiar aspect of this is the relationship that Oswald had with all these guys.
And then you look at what's come out about Oswald's landlady.
She's a super curious character.
What's her name?
She's still alive, bro.
She's like 93.
No way.
Ruth Payne is her name.
Ruth Payne, that's right.
And she somehow...
She was connected with Dulles' mistress, Bancroft.
Am I making that up?
Yeah.
No, this is correct.
She actually vacationed the summer of 1963 at a place called Nashawn Island, which is right up near Martha's Vineyard in Massachusetts.
And Nashawn Island is owned by the Forbes family.
That's John Kerry Forbes, the guy who ran against Bush in 2004.
Yeah.
Right?
They were both skull and bones.
They both went to Yale Secret Society.
The Forbes family hosted this...
Summer retreat at their mansion.
Ruth Payne's there with Alan Dulles, Alan Dulles' mistress.
What they discussed is...
Again, that's not going to be in the JFK files.
It's not going to be in the Kennedy files.
What year were they together there?
63.
So right there.
So right after she leaves Nashawn Island...
Oh, my God.
I think either before she went to Nashawn or after, she visits her sister in Virginia.
Turns out her sister works for the CIA.
That's come out.
Whoa.
Then she goes, picks up Lee and Marie.
In New Orleans and brings them to Dallas, gives them a home,
hooks Lee up with his job at the School Book Depository building,
which, by the way, the School Book Depository building is an interesting...
It's owned by D. Harold Byrd.
Dry Hole Byrd is...
David Harold Byrd is his real name, but they call him Dry Hole Byrd
because he was against something called the Oil Depletion Allowance.
He's an oil man.
And Kennedy wanted to get rid of this Oil Depletion Allowance,
which would have made all the oil people have to basically pay a ton of money.
They wouldn't get this government tax break from Uncle Sam.
So they all hated Kennedy.
They wanted him gone for that reason.
That's why you have the big oil element.
And big oil goes back way long in history.
There's a whole book by Daniel Yergin called The Prize.
And there's a Prize Part Two where he talks about the whole history of oil
with John D. Rockefeller and how he bought out all the railroads
and would only ship his oil through the railroads
so he could basically have a monopoly over the oil business
because none of the other oil companies could ship their oil
because he owned all the railroads.
And that's why, you know, in monopoly, you own all the railroads.
It's part of the game.
And again, he shut all the business and competition out
and they were eventually disbanded with the Antitrust Act
that, you know, broke up all the monopolies, supposedly.
But a lot of these oil people have a real dangerous history of murder
and conspiracy going way back to then, you know, and just doing terrible things.
So, yeah, those guys are involved.
And then D.
Harold Byrd.
Harold Byrd, in addition to being an oil man,
he also buys a bunch of stock in this company called LTV,
Ling Temco Vought.
And he owns this big share in Vought Aerospace.
Well, it turns out Vought Aerospace built all the flying saucers
for Wright-Patterson in the 40s and 50s
under a guy named Alfred C. Loading.
Wait, wait, what?
Yeah.
Really?
What do you mean when you say built the flying saucers?
Like built the Avrocar project, which is on record as a flying saucer?
The Avrocar project was Canada.
But then it got moved to Wright-Patterson as Project Y or Silverbug.
Yeah, okay.
Yeah.
But like, so when you say built flying saucers, because-
So the Vought Flying Pancake is a Vought aircraft.
And it's literally an early attempt to build a flying saucer with propellers.
That was before Avrocar in the 40s.
Yeah, it was way before.
This was even pre-dates then.
That's so interesting.
I hadn't even heard of this.
That's so, wow.
It's very obscure.
It's not well known.
And then LTV, Ling Temco.
Temco Vought.
He gives a bunch of money with Ling.
And they invest in this right before the Kennedy assassination.
And of course, aerospace and all those people made a ton of money off the Kennedy assassination.
And then you have deep space aerospace connections, deep state aerospace connections to Lee Harvey Oswald
because he worked at Atsugi, which is where the CIA was running the U-2 spy plane program.
Whoa.
You know, so.
Well, also, I believe Harold Byrd, who owned the Texas book,
Depository, he was, I think, had some connections with LBJ.
And then he was also connected with Curtis LeMay.
Curtis LeMay gave him an award for the Civil Air Corps when he was younger.
Yes.
And Curtis LeMay hated JFK.
Absolutely.
And, you know, thought that he was, you know, kind of a traitor.
LBJ, LBJ too.
And there's pictures of LBJ and D. Harold Byrd together, like going to football games.
And they were, they were good friends.
So they definitely knew each other.
Definitely.
Maybe the craziest thing.
I mean, JFK, we're painting a picture of him just being 360 surrounded by these, like, you know, spooky people.
The mayor of Dallas was a guy named Earl Cabell.
Yeah.
And his, his brother, Charles, was Dallas's number two at the CIA.
He played on the Bay of Pigs.
There you go.
Yeah.
And, and Earl rerouted JFK's motorcade.
So like.
They took it right by D. Harold Byrd's building.
Right in D. Harold Plaza.
It's like, come on.
Yeah.
Now it gets, it gets even deeper.
It does here.
Yeah, it's, it's crazy, bro.
Cause, uh, you know, D. Harold Byrd, you know, that he has, he's a big hunter, right?
He, he went after JFK got assassinated, he went to Africa on a safari and shot a bunch of elephants, brought their heads back and had them mounted on the wall in his big trophy room.
A big trophy room full of all the animal heads that he, of all the animals he killed and shot.
Yeah.
You know what else he did?
He took the window out of the six, four depository building and he put it in his trophy room at his house.
Wow.
Why?
What, what reason for that?
No way.
That's crazy.
That's fucking weird.
Whoa.
That is like, dude, that's red flags.
That is huge, huge red flags.
And the fact that Ruth Payne knows D. Harold Byrd, she brings the Oswald's to Dallas, gives them this house to live in.
And then all after the assassination, they go to Ruth Payne's garage, find all the evidence that, that, and then about a month after the assassination, after the FBI has already searched the home extensively.
Yeah.
Ruth Payne comes and says, oh, me and Marina found this other, uh, note that he left for Marina, um, supposedly where he, he wrote Marina a note when he supposedly went to go shoot, uh, General Walker and left her a note, but they found this all after the case.
So, and then, then they've used that to blame the shooting of Edwin Walker on Lee Harvey Oswald.
He's, oh, he's, you know, he's killing this, uh, you know, anti-communist, uh, general, which is really weird because, you know, it, it, it doesn't make sense with the narrative of, you know, what is he doing?
Is he just trying to kill someone to get famous?
Is that, is that Lee, who, who we think Lee Harvey Oswald is?
You know, the people get, oh, poor Oswald, you know, it was just this innocent guy who was just a weirdo and he was just a fall guy, you know, and didn't have anything to do with it.
It's not true at all.
He was CIA trained.
Well, he was actually trained by the Office of Naval Intelligence.
It wasn't CIA.
Interesting.
And he was in this thing called Operation Redskin.
It was a whole different operation.
Uh, but the bottom line is he ended up being part of this thing that was called, uh, the, uh.
The field intelligence.
Uh, and it was, it was a kind of a private, uh, spying operation, the political spying operation that was going on.
The William D. Pauly and, uh, and, uh, uh, uh, Hunt, uh, E.H. Hunt and a lot of guys, they were funding it.
And that was a Willoughby, George Willoughby, Charles Willoughby rather.
Cause when, when Truman got not fired, Truman wasn't fired.
He was, he was.
So what were these operations Lee Harvey Oswald was involved in?
He was.
He was doing spying.
He was doing spying on progressive groups.
Okay.
Uh, in, uh, in around the, around New Orleans working with Guy Bannister.
It was true.
Guy Bannister is the FBI guy who's known as like the head of the X-Files, like he's on the weird desk of the FBI.
And so he hit, what was it, 555 Camp Street?
Is that right?
Yeah, 555 Camp Street.
And so, and so Lee Harvey Oswald is working out of that building.
That building mysteriously gets burned down, right?
By, by, uh, by.
By Novell.
Gordon Novell is the guy that was arrested and prosecuted by James Garrison in New Orleans for burning down 555 Camp Street.
The office where, where, uh, where, uh, Lee Oswald.
Wow.
Had the office along with, uh, uh, what was his name?
Uh, the guy that was the hardcore right wing guy that was the head of the Latin American, uh, uh, anti.
Uh, communist league, uh, one of the, the, the guy that was the former FBI guy that was down in New Orleans, the heck was that guy's name, but anyway, he had an office in the same, in the exact same building on the exact same floor with him and, and Gordon Novell was prosecuted and convicted for burning down that building in the midst of, uh, in the midst of the investigation.
That's crazy.
Okay.
Who ends up later.
Later in the UFO, in the UFO conversation, uh, you know, and needs and tried to hire me as his lawyer, Robert Bigelow and stuff.
Okay.
So, so this is all so crazy.
Yeah.
So what is Lee Harvey Oswald doing exactly?
He's inserting himself into like, he's, he, he is, he is, uh, in addition to spying on the different liberal liberal groups like ACLU and other things that he's doing and filing reports with this field intelligence operation going on that, that what he's doing is he's infiltrating the,
the.
Uh, free Cuba group, uh, and pretending to be a Marxist, you know, uh, just like he, when he went to Russia and did all that stuff.
And so what he was doing is he was designing a character of being, uh, involved with Russia and with, uh, with Cuba.
Uh, and what, what the, the plan was is to coax him into taking a shot at the motorcade, not hitting anybody, but taking a shot at the motorcade.
Uh, and then he would, uh, he.
He would, uh, escape, but they would have, they'd figure out who it was.
There's the gun and there's who he is and that they would blame it on Cuba and they could get back to invading the island.
You know, again, it was the same guys, the same guard, hardcore right wing guys that are into this.
And so he's, he's all put into place that can't take this shot at the motorcade and then run and escape.
Uh, and what happens, he takes the shot at the motorcade, hits the curb and chips the, the, the curb.
Uh, the.
Pieces of the cement flying and immediately these other shots ring out, uh, and kill the president right in front of him.
So you think Oswald missed?
Oh, he didn't miss.
He wasn't intending to hit him.
He wasn't even, what was the, what was the point really?
The point was to have a fire, a gun shot fired at the motorcade to be a, a bungled attempt to assassinate the president and blame it on Oswald, who was a Cuban operations guy so that they could then justify invading the island.
Yeah, got it.
Cause that's, that was the whole plan, very subtle plan.
And he was involved in that part.
And when he fired the shot.
Why didn't they end up using him as, oh, like he was this Cuban operative?
Cause they didn't, that didn't end up being the narrative.
Like we need to retaliate against Cuba.
Well, be because, because he killed, he killed, uh, uh, uh, uh, Tippett, the police officer was sent to kill him, you know?
Cause the whole idea is there's a dead guy.
Yeah.
A lone gunman, dead guy, you know, that he took the shot at the president, you rotten bastards, you know, you're a Cuban, you know, spy and, you know.
And what was his association with Cuba prior?
He was, uh, he, he was part of the, uh, uh, Free Cuba group.
He, he infiltrated the group.
That was when he got arrested on the street.
Remember by, by, you know, sitting on the street corner championing Cuba.
Where, what year is this?
In the 1963.
Okay.
1963.
And he's, he's championing Cuba.
And he's championing Free Cuba, like in New Orleans or where?
In, uh, in New Orleans.
Okay.
Yeah.
This is amazing.
So, so he, he was creating this character.
Yeah.
Who was, uh, who was kind of a zany guy who'd been to Russia and it was, uh, in favoring Cuba.
And then he was going to take a shot at the, uh, thing and he thought he was supposed to help get escaped.
Yeah.
The whole theory was he was going to, they were going to help him escape.
Uh, and then, but they were going to blame it on him, but he's already in some safe haven.
But in reality, they were just going to take him out.
They were going to kill him.
And then he killed Tippett.
That's right.
Sort of fumbled the plan.
As soon as he saw Tippett, he just killed him.
Wow.
You know?
And, uh, he got arrested for it.
Yeah.
You know?
And, uh, so then that's why he kept saying, wait a second, I'm just a patsy here.
Something's wrong.
I'd like some legal representation, but these police officers have not allowed me to, to
have any.
I, uh, I don't know what this is all about.
I'm just a black guy.
No, sir, I didn't.
People keep asking me that.
Sir?
I work in that building.
Are you in the building?
Naturally, if I work in that building, yes, sir.
Back up, man.
Did you shoot the president?
No, they're taking me in because of the fact that I live in a Soviet Union.
I'm just a patsy.
Did you shoot the president?
And he tried to place the call.
Yeah.
He asked for the telephone call.
To Nag's head.
Yeah.
Which is Redskin.
Mm-hmm.
That was, that was the whole operation where he was dipped.
That's what he was dipped.
Sheep dipped.
He was erased.
Yeah.
And, and so, so the bottom line in that whole thing, the, the role,
the role of him, you know, it really disappoints half of the, the, the Castro
assas or the, the Kennedy assassination community.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, no, wait a second.
He's supposed to be a completely innocent guy.
He didn't have anything to do with it.
You know, wasn't involved with these people at all.
And they're just these weird things, you know, that, uh, that, uh, Garrison in, in,
in New Orleans was way off base.
Mm-hmm.
You know, but he wasn't.
You know, that, that whole crowd was part of that, you know, and Guy Bannister and
that whole crowd.
Mm-hmm.
Was the head of the, the Central American, uh, chapter of the World Anti-Communist
League.
Mm-hmm.
Wow.
You know?
Uh, you know, that's, that's who they are, you know, and that's what he was part
of.
Mm-hmm.
Uh, and, uh, and so that, that's, that's how the, that's how the thing came down.
And of course, as soon as it happened, all the people that knew about the S-Force
said, holy shit, it's the S-Force.
You know, there's, there's, uh, Rip Robertson, photographs of Rip Robertson,
who's the field, field operations.
Commander for the S-Force.
Mm-hmm.
Standing right there in Dilley Plaza.
You got Ed Lansdale.
Mm-hmm.
You know, the photographs of Lansdale sitting right there and his wife identifying him.
Whoa.
You know?
Uh, and so the, the, you got the S-Force is in town.
Wow.
I mean, you see a Philip, uh, Felipe Fidel Santiago on the grassy knoll.
This guy's like a radio man.
He looks like a Cuban.
He's out of place.
And he's sitting, he's sitting right next to the umbrella man.
Mm-hmm.
And the umbrella man's never been really solved.
They, they came out with this guy they said was the umbrella man in the set.
In 74 at the House Select Committee.
Mm-hmm.
That's not the dude.
Come on now.
There was a different guy there with the umbrella symbolizing you didn't have the umbrella to,
of the air support to help with the Bay of Pigs.
Mm-hmm.
And now we're going to get you.
And also being the signal man on the grassy knoll.
Did you know that there were three yellow painted lines.
Mm-hmm.
Right on the side of the curb where the shot, in, in conjunction where all the shots took
place in the, in the kill zone.
And they were painted the night before because Beverly Oliver was standing on one.
She can be seen in the, in the Zapruder film.
She was standing on the yellow curb on the edge of the, edge of the sidewalk on Elm Street.
Mm-hmm.
And she got yellow paint all over her shoe because it was freshly painted the night before.
Wow.
Now there's no parking on Elm Street so there's no reason to paint the curb yellow.
Everyone, everyone knows there's no parking there.
It's an on-ramp to the freeway, to the Stemmons Freeway.
You know, nobody, nobody pulls over there and parks so there's no reason to paint the curb
unless you're marking the, the shots for the kill zone.
Were there any other actors or, or people worthy of consideration as far as the involvement
in the film?
Yeah, I mean, the, the, the, the question is to how many of the people in Brown Brothers
Harriman had to sign off on this, you know, other than Dulles.
And the, the, the real power was sort of in Sullivan and Cromwell, that whole law firm.
You know, that, that's not a normal law firm, Sullivan and Cromwell.
There was legal counsel for Brown Brothers Harriman.
The Cromwell of Sullivan and Cromwell is the guy that choreographed the, the overthrowing
of the Panamanian War.
Yeah.
Of the Panamanian government to build the Panama Canal.
I mean, it's, it's sort of, it was sort of like, uh, uh, Williams and Connolly.
Mm.
I understand.
Yeah.
It's not like a normal law firm.
Gotcha.
No, that's like Sullivan and Cromwell was that back at those times.
So, so the, the bottom line is that's what happened.
And then as soon as the people realized what had happened, they said, shit, it's the S-Force.
You know, and so we got to do everything in our power to cover this thing up.
Mm-hmm.
Because anybody finds out it's the S-Force, they're going to track it.
All the way back through to the agency and they're going to blame this on the agency.
Mm-hmm.
Uh, whereas it wasn't the agency as such that did it.
It was Dulles, you know, in his capacity as the consigliere, basically for Brown Brothers
Harriman, you know, in that whole China lobby operation.
And so the agency went to great lengths to conceal this.
Uh, and then they briefed LBJ.
LBJ goes and gets ahold of Earl Warren and says, Justice Warren, Chief Justice Warren,
you got this.
You got this.
You got to chair this commission because we've really got to quell any of these concerns
about a conspiracy.
And look at one thing that you got to do.
And he didn't want to do it.
And so he said, look, let me tell you why you have to do this, he said.
Because he says, you've got to be sure to conceal the fact that there was an assassination
team that was assigned to try to kill Castro.
And it was the Kennedys that put it together.
And if the word gets out that there was an assassination team that Kennedy put together
to try to kill Castro.
Everybody's going to believe that Castro found out about it and killed the president.
And if that happens, you know, people are going to go crazy and they're going to try
to make us invade Cuba.
And if we do that, Russia is going to cause a world war.
And he, they lie to Chief Justice Warren, to Chief Justice Warren to get to chair the
Warren commission.
And they put Alan Dulles on the, who's the de facto run guy that ran the Warren commission.
You know, the whole thing to cover them all up.
So crazy to cover the, and, and what people do is people, when they get little pieces
of the information, they say, well, this is the agency that killed him, you know, and
they kill him because he screwed up the Bay of Pigs.
Did they get Jack Ruby to kill?
What, what, what happened with Jack Ruby?
I mean, that's all the mob.
They said, wait, holy shit, we've, we've messed up here.
How did they, how did they manipulate Jack Ruby into killing Lee Harvey Oswald?
He was, he was a made man.
He was a made man of the, of the mob.
You know, when they tell you, you know.
Do you think they MKUltra'd him?
Because he says he didn't remember killing Lee Harvey Oswald for a long time.
No, I don't think that's true.
You don't think so?
That's just.
But that, okay.
But so then, yeah, maybe, maybe not, you know, for the actual killing, but then he ends up
in jail and he claims that he doesn't remember killing Lee Harvey Oswald, but is pretty lucid.
And then he's seen court ordered by a psychiatrist who is on record as being part of MKUltra,
a guy named Jolly West, who is letters between him and Sidney Gottlieb, we, you know, are
fairly sure that.
He was involved in CIA mind control stuff and he sees Jack Ruby for 24 hours, totally
not filmed, you know, and comes out, Jack Ruby has a psychotic break and he starts,
you know, saying that there are Jews outside his jail cell screaming or whatever, and is
never the same after that.
Yeah.
And Jolly West does a press conference saying Jack Ruby has gone crazy, you know, he's lost
his marbles or whatever.
Yeah.
And so.
So he can't depend on anything he says.
Yeah.
I mean, that's gotta be pretty.
But that, but that would imply that the first time around he wasn't, he wasn't MKUltra because
maybe he had something to share and they needed to scramble his brain.
Yeah.
To cover it up.
And the thing is, is that just following Occam's razor, you get a real simple line and narrative
of what really happened.
And then all kinds of activities that are undertaken to cover up and conceal this, you
know, end up being interpreted as you're a principal involved in making the plan to kill
him.
Uh, because it makes, it satisfies people's other more sinister worldview.
Right.
But, but, but the bottom line is that, that the, the threat that was going to come unraveled
happened with the Watergate burglary.
Cause what happened is when, as soon as the democratic national committee chooses Larry
O'Brien.
Yeah.
To be the new head of the democratic national committee, it turns out previously 20 years,
he was the chief lobbyist for, for Howard Hughes in Washington.
This is an.
Amazing part of your narrative, which is that Larry O'Brien is the number two or chief
lobbyist for Howard Hughes.
Howard Hughes was responsible on behalf of Nixon for setting up, you know, the S force
and working with traffic content.
Yep.
And so, uh, Nixon is cause he was a longtime political opponent of JFK is freaked out that
he's cause he's running for president later.
Yes.
Um, is in the, you know, so this is in the seventies.
He says he's, he's freaked out that.
Yeah.
Basically Larry O'Brien is going to out him as having killed his long time political opponent,
even though he set up the S force not to kill JFK, it was to take out Castro and Che Guevara,
but he's freaked out that they have compromise on him.
And if you look at what happened in the Watergate scandal, the burglary, it's James McCord is
involved.
You represented him, you know, in the one that afterwards McCord was known as Dulles
is number two and his favorite guy or whatever it was, you know, his favorite understudy.
And they put it, they bugged Larry O'Brien's phone, so clearly they were targeting him.
And Nixon was way up against McGovern in the polls in that election.
So you always have to ask the question.
Was it like he was paranoid, but was he that paranoid?
Like, why would he do that?
If it weren't this sort of specific thing he was worried about.
That's right.
Because, because if O'Brien were to reveal the fact that he's the one that created the assassination team that in fact killed the
president.
There's no way you can talk your way out of that in an election year from June, between June and November, he's not going to climb out from under that.
And so he said, we've got to, we've got to find out whether, whether O'Brien knows about it and is thinking at all about using it.
So we've got to not only wiretap his telephone, but bug his office.
That's amazing.
And that's what they did.
And they sent him in to do it.
So you, you then are the lawyer for James McCord.
Well, it was Bailey.
It was Bailey himself.
Because Bailey, it turns out was on index four.
For the agency, which, which we didn't know, you know, none of us knew it in the office.
Did you learn anything from those guys about like spooky Intel world or like, did, did any of them sort of reveal any secrets?
Like McCord, did you interact with McCord at all?
No.
Okay.
Did, uh, but, but I, I knew that McCord was, was, was, uh, didn't want to plead guilty.
He was refusing to plead guilty.
He said, why am I pleading guilty?
You know, that we got, because he had been told.
That they were going in to, to try to find evidence that, that, uh, O'Brien and the other guys were, were coordinating and financing anti-war demonstrators.
Yeah.
Uh, and he wanted to get that information.
So he thought he was involved in kind of a, a typical kind of, you know, uh, uh, I guess meat and potatoes kind of covert operation by the agency.
Uh, and they've been instructed that if you get caught doing a covert operation for the agency stateside, which is totally illegal.
Call one of the people on the index for, you know, there's William Bennett Williams and then there's a Bailey and there was this other guy Miller I knew about, you know, but, but I didn't know any of that when Bailey contacted me and asked me to come over to his shop to, to be special counsel, uh, you know, for the burglary case.
I want to pivot slightly.
It's the same sort of, uh, you know, world that we're talking about here, but, um, you have a very interesting narrative about how some of maybe the initial financing occurs for secret covert UFO programs in America.
Oh yeah.
And, uh, you, you talk about this Anderson trust and, uh, you know, billions of dollars worth of lost gold.
1.2 trillion.
There you go.
At $32 an ounce.
Unbelievable.
Which is now $3,400.
So what's, what's the story there?
Well, it's the, the, what happened is back in about 19, about 2000, uh, it was just like 2000 year, 2000 that, uh, uh, Mr. IA, who is like the third richest fellow in the entire Philippines, you know, uh, contacts the Jesuit headquarters that he wanted to, he wanted to have somebody from the Jesuit headquarters.
Cause he'd gone to a Jesuit high school and college and stuff and wanted them to come in brief to talk.
Uh, he wanted to talk to the top 50 business people in the Philippines about what the consequences of global climate change were going to be for the island.
You know, where the rising sea levels is going to swamp parts of the island and ruin businesses.
Uh, and so trying to see if they would mobilize the business community to do something about it.
Right.
So I got designated to go brief him.
So I fly, I fly to the Philippines, uh, and Mr. IA puts me up in this like 20 star hotel.
You know, with these, these.
There was food everywhere, all this bizarre kind of offensive kind of opulence.
And I go brief these guys and I tell them that what they should do is they should try to mobilize and get the government of the Philippines, which they had some influence with, these rich business guys, you know, to lead the Association of Island States in the United Nations,
to mobilize a motion on the floor of the General Assembly to have a uniting for peace resolution, to have the island states all join together and accuse the United States and China and India of aggressive activities ruining their national security by the fostering and promoting of the fossil fuels that are swamping their islands and ruining their country.
And if you can get, I told him, if you can get.
Two thirds of all the members of the General Assembly, the 193 countries at that time, you know, to support such a resolution, you can get an investigation done.
And if you can get three fourths of them to vote for a resolution ordering those countries to start cutting back on all of their, the use of petroleum, you can enforce it.
And the Security Council can't veto it.
Okay.
So I explained that all to them.
And then Mr. Aya drives me up to.
His big mansion on top of the mountain overlooking Manila.
And we're sitting there, you know, sipping lemonade at the afternoon.
And he said, you know, would you like to meet the president of the Senate of the Philippines?
And I said, yeah, that would be really helpful if we could get right to them.
You know, and he said, well, let me get a hold of him.
He gets up and leaves.
He goes in, makes a call.
He comes back.
He says, good, let's go down and see him.
So we go get in his big Cadillac.
We drive down off the hill.
He walks into.
To the office of the president of the Senate says hi to the secretary and we just walk in, we sit down.
He introduces me to Senator Pimentel, who is the president of the, of the Philippine Senate.
And, uh, I'm briefing him on this, how to go about, you know, spearheading, organizing the association of island states to bring on a motion under the uniting for peace resolution.
And, uh, he's, he's listening to me, but he doesn't seem particularly enthralled about it all.
Uh, and so then he.
He casually gets up and goes over and he closes the door and comes and sits back down.
He said, well, I should tell you, he said, as the president of the, of the Senate, you know, I chair a thing called the blue ribbon commission and the blue ribbon commission is charged with finding these 176 troves of treasure that have been buried in the Philippines by general Yakushima at the end of a world war two.
Uh, and each of them has like a hundred billion dollars.
Of gold.
And silver, uh, in the platinum bars and big 50 gallon drums of diamonds and rubies and, and precious jewels that have all been pilfered by a special unit of the Japanese army that was deployed all during the 1930s before world war two started, uh, as a treasure, a war chest for the, the war.
Because they were, and they were worried about being invaded or taken.
Well, they, yeah, because they, they knew that, that once the Germans had surrendered in May of 1945.
It was just a matter of time that the U S was going to invade the island, you know, and, and take them down.
Uh, and so they, they were going to move all of the, the treasure out of there, uh, out of Japan and they're going to bury it.
And they were going to sign general Yakushima himself to oversee all that.
And they were going to send the, uh, the cousin, I think, of, uh, of, uh, Hiroshito, you know, uh, to a, a prince, a Japanese prince of the royal family.
Mm-hmm.
So he would know where all 176 of these treasure troves were.
Uh, and so they sent them into the islands and they started moving the gold out in the last months of the war and they buried it.
Uh, and they buried them in these like, you know, like, you know, 500, 600 feet deep, you know, big wells like that they drilled.
Uh, and then they were using, uh, prisoners of war to do the digging and then burying the team that dug that particular hole.
Burying them with the gold so that no one would know, uh, be around to tell where it was.
So where did, where did this gold end up?
It ended up in the Philippines.
There's 176 troves of these things.
Is it still there?
Still there.
Oh, yeah.
So there is 1.5 trillion or $1.2 trillion worth of gold in the Philippines now?
Oh, 1.2 trillion was just about, just 12 of the troves.
There's 176 of them.
And they're still there?
Yes, they're still there.
So who's guarding over them?
They, they don't, they can't find them.
That, that's what the problem is.
They're, they're crazy people running around the Philippines for decades trying to find these places.
No way.
But they don't, they don't know where they are.
But you, but we have documentation that there are a lot of these.
Oh, yeah.
That, that, that, uh, Marcos got two of them.
Yeah.
Uh, by, by capturing one of the guys who was, uh, who, who, who found one of them and they drilled the eyes out of his son right in front of him with a hot poker.
Jesus.
Marcos did.
Colonel Ver, you know, did it.
Who is, who's Marcos?
Marcos was the president of the, of the Philippines.
Whoa.
That, uh, that was, uh.
Who drilled, who drilled the.
General Ver was his kind of chief torturer and, uh, he tortured this guy's son right in front of him to get the guy to tell him where two of these little troves were, you know, and, uh, they got two of them.
Uh, Marcos got two of them, each of a hundred billion dollars.
What?
But, but.
So what does this have to do with UFO financing?
Well, the, the, no.
The, the.
It doesn't as such.
What, what we know is that the, at the end of World War II, after they had done this, after they'd buried them all.
Uh-huh.
And there were maps.
Of, of them.
That's what, what happened is that, uh, Lansdale, Ed Lansdale, who was in the OSS.
Uh-huh.
When they disbanded the OSS after the Germans, uh, uh, surrendered in May of 45, the Truman disbanded the OSS and reassigned them all around.
And Ed Lansdale, who was an OSS.
He was an OSS guy.
He gets made the G2, uh, in Manila.
Right?
And he knows about the fact that this treasure has been buried around there.
And so what he does is when, when, uh, General Yakushima turns himself in, you know, at the end of the war, after the dropping the bombs, you know, in the, in August, the sixth and eighth of 45, you know, they all surrender.
Uh, so there's not going to be any kind of, uh, invasion to the, but, and what, what, uh, Japan was hoping that they could get a conditional.
Surrender, uh, and that they would be able to keep custody of the Philippines so that they'd be able to then later go in and dig these things up and have, you know, re, uh, constitute the wealth of the Japanese empire.
Right.
That was the plan, but the US bombs them instead, uh, and says, you know, it's an unconditional surrender.
You don't get the Philippines.
We keep the Philippines.
Right.
And so, and so what happens is, is, uh, Ed Lansdale.
Ed Lansdale, uh, knows that these are here.
And so these, these treasure troves are there.
So what he does is he, he kidnaps the driver for General Yakushima who would know where the, some of them were.
Right.
And so he has him tortured.
This guy means Santa Maria, Santa Mario, uh, uh, Santa Mario.
Yeah, it's his name.
Uh, this corporal that actually conducted the torture.
He conducted the torturing of, of this driver, uh, and they find out where 12 of the troves are.
Uh, so they punched the first one, uh, and find the hundred billion dollars.
Uh, I've seen photographs of the, I mean, it looks, it's like a football stadium down underneath the ground.
You know, they goes down like five, 600 feet, huge cave caverns down there and stacks of gold bullion, you know, you know, armpit high, as far as you can see, you know, and big barrels of gold.
You know, and big barrels of jewels everywhere.
And the bottom line is they, they punch 12 of these things.
And so, uh, so Lansdale, uh, after punching the first one and verifying that, that it's for real, he gets in a plane and he flies, uh, from Manila to Singapore to see MacArthur.
And he goes in to see MacArthur, uh, personally, he starts to tell him what they've got here.
Right.
And MacArthur brings in his G2, who's Charles Willoughby.
Mm-hmm.
And, uh, the, the, and so, uh, MacArthur orders Willoughby to go with Ed Lansdale in MacArthur's private plane.
And they fly him from Singapore back to Manila, back into the, uh, the, the Philippines and back into the United States.
Right.
And they, they go to see Truman.
Uh-huh.
To tell Truman that they've got $1.2 trillion.
Uh, in gold bullion and, and, and platinum and, and, uh, and, uh, silver and, and jewels.
Uh, and the, the chief of staff won't let them see him, uh, unless he, they tell him what they want to talk about.
So they brief the chief of staff, who is Clark Clifford.
So Clifford comes into the meeting, uh, with Truman, uh, with, uh, Ed Lansdale and with Willoughby.
And they start to brief Truman about what they've got.
Truman says, hold it a second.
I've, I've got to bring, uh, uh, Stimson in.
Brings in the secretary of war, uh, Stimson.
Uh, Stimson.
Brings him in.
And as soon as Stimson starts realizing what they've got, he sends for his three deputies.
And he, he brings in Robert Lovett, uh, and Robert Anderson.
Both, not only deputies, secretaries of war, but senior partners in Brown Brothers Harriman and, and John J. McCloy.
And they bring them in, the three deputies.
They find out what they've got here.
And Truman decides that what he's going to do, he's not going to tell anybody.
He's not going to tell the Congress.
He's not going to tell anybody else.
He's not going to tell anybody else about it.
They're going to set up this secret, uh, uh, trust.
Uh, they call it the Anderson Trust.
And they set it up down in Houston, Texas.
And they, they set up the, the Anderson Trust.
And they have all this.
And they, they assign, we, we now know we've got the, he's still alive.
The, the, the commander, the pilot that flew the, flew the gold out.
He's alive.
Yes, he's alive.
Have you spoken to him?
No, I'm going to.
Whoa.
We're going to.
We, we know right where he is now.
And, and I'm going to, I'm going to talk to him.
You know, to get this thing on the record.
Whoa.
Yeah.
But so the, so they fly the, using U.S. military transport.
They fly these, these, this gold all out of there.
You know, these 12 troves of it.
And they bring it to the International Credit Bank in Geneva, Switzerland.
And then they deposit it there.
And then they issue gold certificates on it, which are like bearer bonds.
You know, and, and they, they make, they distribute them to right-wing anti-communist candidates.
Mm-hmm.
For mayors.
And they do that kind of stuff after World War II.
You know, all throughout Europe.
Whoa.
And there, so there's this whole covert program of.
So this has nothing to do with the UFOs.
No.
Oh.
Okay.
No, no, no.
But, but what it is is it's a, it's a mechanism for secretly funding covert operations.
Yeah.
That are going on after World War II.
When the CIA is set up.
Yeah.
And they're all funding this stuff.
And that's Dulles.
Yeah.
Knows about this money that's there.
And so that they're, they're using this for covert operations.
Interesting.
You know?
And yeah, that's wild.
Yeah.
That's wild.
It's, it's, it's totally separate from the, the UFO stuff.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think Chris Ramsey, who just did a great interview with you.
Yeah.
Told me, maybe he thought it had something to do with UFOs.
So.
No, no.
I'll use this as a, a opportunity to say, Chris, why'd you lead me astray?
And, but go watch your interview with Chris.
Cause I thought that was great.
I don't know if you've seen it.
No, I haven't seen it.
But it was fantastic.
I know.
It was really great.
Yeah.
I don't, I don't see, I don't see most of these things.
I just, you know, when I.
Yeah.
With somebody that I trust, anyway, that I can just tell you.
Until it's done.
There.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Until I know that you guys will tell other people.
Check it out.
Area 52.
Yeah.
In that interview, you actually talk about an interview with a live alien being.
At S4.
That's right.
In Area 51.
And yeah, care to go into any details.
Yeah.
I'm just trying to think of any detail around that.
Well, yeah.
I got, at Jesuit headquarters, I mean you see it must've be about, uh, let's see when
that would be.
Uh, it was 94, I'd already done the, uh, the John Mack stuff.
Uh, so it was, it was like 2000, 2001, 2002, something like that, that, uh, I get a call
from a guy.
Uh.
northern minnesota and he's uh on his deathbed well he's actually in hospice right uh and he
wants me to come and see him there's something and he says that he worked directly with project
blue book and so i said uh oh uh okay so i fly there and fly into minneapolis and rent a little
car and drive up into this little teeny town up in northern minnesota uh and there he is he's at
this little hospice place with he's got one of these little rollers with all the little bottoms
on it stuff in his nose and he starts telling me how uh he was a uh a clerk typist army u.s army
clerk typist assigned to this special unit of project blue book that was focusing just on the
700 or so uh cases of of instance incidents which they couldn't explain away they were just too
credible the source
was too credible they had too many people had seen what was his name that is his name was uh
oscar uh wolf oscar oscar wolf or oscar lane oscar wolf yes oscar wolf uh-huh that's who he was uh
and uh and uh he he starts telling me about it all uh and it goes into detail about it uh now
it's one of these bizarre things because i my my office people said you've got to bring a camera
you got to bring a camera you got to bring a camera you got to bring a camera you got to bring a
camera you got to bring a camera to get this guy if he's going to give you a did you record him
yeah i i brought the little thing i set it all up on the little table and and so i had the whole
the whole thing recorded uh and it got corrupted somehow but i think jeremy corbell might have
recorded an interview with this guy separately later yeah he did and he also he also talked
with richard dolan okay so we have him on record that's right oscar and well they but the thing is
of them as far as i know about this incident oh really and he and he told me about the fact that
he because i kept they missed the they buried the lead well yeah because i was interrogating the
shit out of him you know i was just pressing down on him because i figured he was a poor guy
so so so yeah don't don't mess with me so
shape up you know he's dying i could have been worse i could have said you know if you want
any absolution you know but i didn't do that part
man the jesuits are thugs that's that's being too tough you know and so so so the bottom line
he tells me that that uh that the reason that he has developed this kind of special relationship
with the commander of this unit that is assigned specifically to investigate the the uh the these
700 other cases right is because he and the commander were both part of this really fundamentalist
christian sect called the
worldwide church of god i mean apparently really hardcore fundamentalist crowd and and uh and so
that he stayed there for years and when they were working on his people would come and go in the
staff and do field investigations and all that but he kept staying there and keeping records
and then his commander comes in and said that he is going to be going to area 51
and uh wanted wanted oscar to come with him and so he did he went with him but it turns out it
was not just area 51 it was s4 so they actually went all the way to s4 uh and went down the big
elevators and went in and he said he saw like three or four by the way s4 isn't supposed to
officially exist so it's important the only versions where it exists you have bob lazar
you have a guy named dan barish and you have this story that's right and i think we're going to get
some more corroboration soon that s4 does in fact exist and then then all of a sudden you start
asking questions about these specific stories and
starts to blow your mind okay so you're going down so so he goes down and he says and he sees
like there's three or four uh ufos that are just they they've got little like uh little garages
like these these little chambers it's the same story as bob lazar and they're just they're just
hovering in there they're just he said they were just they're just hovering all by themselves
inside these little garages like that were underground he said he saw them uh and then
they went in and his his commander
was going to be quote interviewing a live et guy right so he goes with him and they come into this
other area where there were military guys there he said but there was this room like a standalone
room with these big two-way mirrors that that you can see through uh from the outside and he said he
saw the et guy but he was like you know five and a half feet tall no wasn't a little tiny short guy
life-size guy big big head big eyes and he was in this kind of jumpsuit that they'd provided for him
uh and he was he was very cooperative that he wasn't being interrogated speaking English or no
no he was it was all telepathic it was all telepathic they just he just saw them sitting
across he could see he could see his commander walk in but he wouldn't go because he said he
said I thought it was demonic that's what he said he said I thought it was demonic and I didn't want
to decide and but he could see his his commander having this kind of telepathic communication going
on with him and his commander was a fundamentalist Christian yeah yes and so how what was the
communication like that that he didn't say he just said that was telepathic he could tell that they
were having this telepathic well he probably afterwards got it confirmed by his his commander
that it was all telepathic they weren't talking you could just see that they were having this
kind of communication did he seem honest to you oh yes
oh yes so you think that happened yeah I do think that happened I think that happened you know and
so you think we have alien beings at S4 well no no all I all I know is I think that there was one
there okay at that time and that he saw him uh and that he he stayed outside and the the military
guys that were there showed him these these cards they had he said they had these index cards that
uh and it didn't say whether they were typed up or printed
but they had the questions and answers that were there of things they'd ask him right and so they
had a little record of interviews that have been conducted with him and then one of them he said
that uh they asked him you know so where are you guys from what are you what are you doing here and
he said that you know he was part of a group uh of people beings from different star systems
in our Galaxy he said and that their job
was to go around monitoring where life had started in different planets inside the Galaxy uh in that
that was what they did uh and that's what they were doing here and he said uh they asked him
well who's who tasked you to do that you know who's in charge of that he said well it's what
you people would refer to as God but it's very different than you think then how is it different
employee and he said but I didn't believe him he said because I thought he was demonic so I never
told anybody I never told anybody about this have you ever heard the term Collins Elite yes do you
think that the this kind of fundamentalist Christian commander was involved in the Collins
Elite no it didn't seem to be this is kind of an individual thing with him and this guy because
they also thought that the the alien stuff was kind of demonic oh yeah no no that there's there's
a whole whole stream of that in
fundamentalist world you know i've got you know that sarah's uh sister-in-law
is a big fundamentalist you know and she will she thinks the whole thing is demonic
it's a meme have you ever interviewed i mean i'm sure part of it is and part of it might be
angelic and you know it's like probably i think that is because people don't understand
that whole part people understand angelic it's probably good and bad is probably way too
simplistic of a frame for whatever they're operating on and i'm sure they're good ones
that incidentally do violence to you because if they're kind of you know field or whatever
once you know it's like saint prince saint francis of assisi has a vision of this you know
kind of you know winged angel being it was a flaming torch in the original translation but
as a seraphim and it does violence to him but it's like it's that becomes part of his conversion
towards god and it ends up sort of killing him but i think the sort of good bad you know
dichotomy is probably a earthly one yeah well there's there's i mean an awful lot of
anthropomorphic projection you know onto these folks because they because they're so much like
us i mean you know that that's a real challenge have you ever met an alien no would you want it
sure really sure yeah i'd like to sit down and chat with them yeah and and actually figure out
you know how to kind of represent us yeah
you know in in a full way about good and bad stuff that we do all of us you know but try to
figure out what the criteria are for trying to establish a relationship of trust with them
and how we could trust them what can they do to kind of assuage the concerns that people have
about them yeah in their kind of secretive ways you know have you ever seen so you've seen picture
of a ufo which was in the blue book files and a skiff in dc
and you even um it wasn't a skiff though oh it wasn't a skiff okay it was just it was just a room
that they had downstairs in the madison and you traced the uh symbols that were along the edge
of the craft i did um have you ever seen anomalous material no i've seen photographs of the of this
thing that hal had i've seen photographs what thing that i had that piece of metal that's got
like 17 different layers of of different is that magnesium bismuth yes
yeah yeah i've just seen the layers thinner than a micron or whatever that's right that's the one
i've seen photographs what do you think of you know how put offs this sort of godfather architect
of the space he's just uh you know seems to have his hand in everything um what do you think of
and his role and kind of ufology i think i think hal is uh is more knowledgeable
in depth about this whole thing
than most any of the people that you would meet you know can and know uh you know in the that uh
do you think he says everything he knows no oh no no he doesn't even pretend to uh-huh no he doesn't
even pretend to say everything he knows do you think he's worked on a craft or seen a craft oh
i'm sure he has you're sure he has no i'm completely sure he has really yeah do you think he knows how
they fly no he has a better idea of how they fly than most anybody
you know there may be some technicians that that know more about some details do you think he
understands a lot about sort of um i don't know uh the mental networks and that sort of thing do
you think he's sort of clued into that oh yeah oh i mean the the that's his major focus from
stargate is is yeah what's the connection between remote viewing and you know so you had these guys
in the remote viewing program like stargate you know which was formed by the cia and
later running out of the dia 1972 he um you know that some of these guys like ingo swan would like
remote view alien bases on the moon and things like that but do you think i talked to ingo about
it did you yeah i spent like a whole day with ingo in no way apartment in new york what did
ingo say about the alien bases it was interesting that that that my my access to him came through
the church of scientology thing you know that that's a big deal yeah uh that church of science
helped put off in search of scientology and in the uh targ russell targ was church of scientology
all kinds of the guys were to catch people up you kind of won l ron hubbard's favor by uh you know
there was a case against them around uh you know special exemption you know as a as a religious
organization and uh there were you know i think they were they were being bugged for a little bit
and they were sort of trying to plug the federal government they were trying to track the federal
government they had they had the door of their headquarters
chainsaw it off right by the by the irs and then you and fbi you were sort of helping them out and
then you made it you were about to like sign on formally as their counsel and then you asked them
for their no no that wouldn't be the way to look i was asked to be there you were asked to be there
and i said look as a condition precedent to even begin to talk with ron hubbard because he wanted
to meet with me and try to persuade me to become the lawyer for him and his wife specifically not
necessarily for the church
but for him and his wife uh and that uh the the head guardian from the from north america came to
my office at the jesuit headquarters and said that uh that uh mr hubbard would like to talk
with you about becoming the lawyer for him and his wife susan and i said well i said look as a
condition precedent to even being willing to meet with him to talk with him i'd have to be given
permission to have access to whatever records or information there is anywhere in the world
about the church uh and i said that's i assume that's a total non-starter right and they give
you their records within a week they came back and said it's a deal no way what do you want to see
and so you could query anybody's e-meter results anything i could get anything i wanted and so uh
they flew me down to uh to florida uh and the big blue cube they've got down there this big
huge blue building uh and uh so i go in and there's the head of the guardian's office u.s
and the international head of the guardians you know out of the uk uh and they say uh said so
what do you want to see and i said uh well first what i want to see is the file you've got on me
in the american guys said no white no we've got no i don't know and i said excuse me i said what
do you think i fell off some melon wagon somewhere i said you're gonna have me be elrond hubbard's
tourney and you don't have any file on me at all and the international guy says go get him the file
so they bring me the file. I'm going through it. How deep was it? How much stuff did they have?
Well, they had pictures of me. I was a Jesuit candidate. I was at the headquarters. They were
following me around. They showed me different restaurants and meeting with people, Mark Lane
and some of the other guys. So Mark Lane, he was like a Kennedy assassination investigator.
Yeah. Arrested judgment. He was the author of that. So they had all these kinds of things.
And so I said, okay, good. I just wanted to make sure that it was accurate.
And then so the international guy says to me, he says, okay, so what else do you want to see?
I said, I want to see the three most sensitive files in the entire world, according to you as
the head of the guardian's office. And he just went, oh, fuck, he said. I said, so either you
get them or not. So he gets up and is gone and revels around, comes back and he ends up laying
one of the files in front of me. And I started looking at it and it was all reports by Ingo
Swann.
Ingo Swann was filing reports with the head guardian office in the UK about the entire
internal operations of the Office of Naval Intelligence remote viewing program that they
were doing. He was just giving them all the information.
So he was a spy or something?
Yeah. Well, he was a spy for the Church of Scientology.
For the Church of Scientology?
Over and against the Office of Naval Intelligence.
Why would he do that?
Because he was a high level clearer. That was his loyalty group.
So he was a
fundamental loyalty.
He was loyal to them prior to...
That's right. That's right. Over and above the country.
Because I always thought Puthoff was looking into that stuff, because he was an NSA guy before he was
a Scientology guy. So I thought Puthoff was just tasked to looking into this very
para-governmental intelligence organization that is Scientology that's seen as a threat,
and so get put off in there.
No, this was a sub... I mean, the Church of Scientology, you're not aware of it,
but their highest principle in the Church of Scientology is all to do with UFOs.
Really?
Yeah. They believe that there is a
major confrontation going on between the human-like people from the Pleiades
over and against the reptilians from Zeta Reticuli. And that there's a major confrontation
going on over which of them is going to actually assert major relations with our planet.
Do you agree with that worldview?
No, I don't ... But Swan was like fully in with the Scientologists.
Oh yeah, he too.
He was giving them information on the Office of Naval Intelligence.
All of it.
And so you're also saying that there's a remote viewing program that was deeper
than Stargate, because that wasn't Office of Naval Intelligence, that was DIA after
CIA.
No, this was a program, and Pat Price, I'll give you some idea how deep this goes, Pat
Price, you know, they had the file, Ingo Swan had the file that Pat Price had gotten so
good at remote viewing that they assigned him a task of, they gave him the exact longitude
and latitude down to the minute and second of a location, and he was assigned an artist
so that he didn't have to do these hand scratches trying to show it.
But he was saying, you know, so what's there?
So there's this major building here, and there's a big fence up with razor wire on the top
of it and everything.
And his facilitator was running it.
Russell Targ.
And so Russell's saying, okay, now can you get inside the fence?
Can you see anything inside the fence?
And he goes, yeah, okay, all right, yeah, I can see inside the fence.
There's just this no man's land there.
Can you get to the front door of this place?
And he said, all right.
He said, okay, all right, I got it, yeah, okay, I'm in front of the front door.
He said, can you go inside the building?
And he said, let me see here, okay, yeah, yeah, I can see inside the building here.
And he said, so what do you see?
He said, there's this big long hallway.
And there's some doors on both sides, and Russell said, now go down to the third door
on the left.
And he said, okay, and he said, can you go into the room?
Yeah, I can go into the room.
So what do you see?
Well, there's a big desk there and chairs and stuff, there's a big file cabinet over
in the right corner over here.
Go over to the file cabinet.
He goes over to the file cabinet, there's a second drawer, first file.
Read it to him.
And he did.
What was it?
Well, that's not the point.
The point is that he did it, and he can do it.
It turns out it's an American facility.
It's a top CIA security facility, and he penetrated it.
That's insane then.
So anybody with remote viewing skills can get the nuclear codes?
Not anybody, but Pat Price could.
The best.
So that's Pat Price, right?
And in the same file, it points out that Pat Price had actually evolved to the point where
they could take a full photograph of a boomer class Russian submarine.
Nuclear submarine, and show it to him and say, where is it right now?
And he would give them right down to the exact longitude and latitude, down to the minute
and second of exactly where that is.
And he visualized the whole thing and told them exactly where it was.
But there was a huge UFO right over the top of the water where that thing was.
And it was tracking it and monitoring it.
And he had it in the file.
I'm going, whoa.
I said, this is pretty wild.
And then I said, OK, so what else have you got?
He says, well, here.
And I said, show me the second file, and he showed me the second file.
And it was, again, from Ingo Swann.
It was a deep inside report from Ingo Swann that they had taken Pat Price in the program
up to southern Canada, south central Canada, just north of the state of Michigan.
And he was in it.
They brought him to this little facility.
It was like this little domed little building.
And it had these big, huge dishes on top, these communication dishes on top.
And they brought him in.
And they sat him down.
And they put this helmet on him.
And they had him think a particular message.
And they turned all the antenna down to the northern peninsula of Michigan, that little
section that's in there, and had him be telepathically projecting, when it comes time for you to
file your national, your US income tax forms next year, file them in this little post office
box down in this little town down in West Virginia.
And 85% of the people did it next year.
No way.
Absolutely way.
That's insane.
You keep saying that.
So you're saying that Scientology had some sort of...
Mass mind control technique.
That wasn't the Church of Scientology.
What was it?
This was the program.
That was the program, the Office of Naval Intelligence.
But that's like...
The implications of that are crazy.
No, they're profound.
Yeah.
And so then I, from then...
So you met Ingo Swann.
Yeah.
I didn't say no to them then.
But as soon as I saw the file on the fair game, I knew I wasn't gonna do it.
But I had the opportunity to go see Ingo.
So I contacted Ingo and said, you know, I'm being asked to be the lawyer.
Yeah.
I'm gonna be the lawyer for Hubbard, and I wanna chat with you.
So I went to see him at his apartment in New York, and we go all the way upstairs up onto
the roof of his apartment that he's got there, and then I started talking to him.
And I didn't wanna freak him out over the fact that he was clearly violating his security
clearance by providing these reports to the Church of Scientology.
So he was using his remote viewing from...
He was using his remote viewing from Stargate in the reports that he was giving to the Church
of Scientology.
Yeah.
He was filing not only about his work, but Pat Price's work, you know, all the things
that he was doing.
He was reporting to the Guardian.
So he's basically like, he was a back-channel spy to the Church of Scientology on behalf
of them, vis-a-vis the federal government of the US.
It was clearly his major loyalty...
Wow.
...allegiance was to them.
Did you ask him about...
Well, he wrote a book called Penetration about seeing bases, alien bases on the moon.
Yeah.
I hadn't seen that at the time.
You hadn't seen that?
Did you get into the alien thing at all with him, or...?
Oh, yeah.
Because...
What did he say?
Because he, in one of his reports, had a report in there about...
It was Hal Puthoff...
No, it wasn't Hal.
It was Targ.
Russell Targ had been facilitating...
Russell Targ had been facilitating a remote viewing by Pat Price when they stepped it
up from him being able to remote view things in real time to be able to be shown a photograph
of a Russian Boomer submarine, and then he could locate it.
He could figure out exactly where it was down to the minute and second of longitude and
latitude, I mean, which was the big deal.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
I mean, that's the big deal.
And when they found it, when they found it and verified that it was there through the
remote viewing, others to find it, there was a UFO hovering right over the top of where
the Russian Boomer submarine was going under the water, and it was monitoring it.
And when I saw it, I just went, whoa.
Did you see a photo?
No.
Okay.
No, they just told me about it.
Yeah.
They just told me about it, that it was there, and it was following right along where the
Russian Boomer submarine was going, and that was the only piece that was in there, except
when I started interrogating people, because I wanted to get as much advantage as I could
of the opportunity that I had here to get information.
So I got to meet the guy who was legal counsel for the church to ask him to explain to me
what the net-net of all this was.
What were they up to here?
And what it is, is that they considered themselves entitled to being considered a sovereign entity,
because the Catholic Church was.
So the Catholic Church has this kind of status of being a sovereign entity in a nation, basically,
because they have Vatican State, right?
So they insisted that as a matter of First Amendment equal protection, that they were
entitled to take unto themselves the same status, and so that's what caused them to
be engaged in this fair game.
They believed that they had a right to engage in, like, wet operations, you know, like the
United States does, and Russia does, and all of that, which they asserted, you know, the
Vatican does, they said.
Do you think that the Vatican, and specifically maybe the Knights of Malta, had anything to
do with the UFO kind of reverse engineering, or transport, or oversight?
I think that an element of the Knights of Malta have something to do with everything.
And why do you think that?
Because of the people.
Well, they were in this Monte Carlo group.
There's a thing called the Monte Carlo group that is at the top of the entire Knights of
Malta structure, and I discovered that there were non-Catholics in it, which didn't make
any sense to me at all, because the Knights of Malta is a Catholic men's club-like thing.
But there's this high executive council that turned out that Henry Kissinger was on it,
and George Bush Senior was on it, who's Episcopal.
That's amazing.
But if I were to play devil's advocate, I could have said, Council of Foreign Relations,
Bilderberg, you know, like, I could name five other organizations that those two guys were
a part of.
Any other reasons to believe they had something to do with the UFO thing, specifically?
No, just, not specifically, but I'm saying is that anybody who is at that level, dealing
with international things, would have to do that.
Yeah.
You can't be involved in this.
There's no way that you're not going to be involved in this, because, I mean, you could
be involved in all the other stuff and it wouldn't make any difference, ultimately.
You know, I mean, this whole thing could, to use a phrase, trump, you know, everything.
What is the, is there kind of a mandate or, you know, constitution for the Knights of
Malta?
I mean, the only references I really have are, you know, Humphrey Bogart, the Maltese
falcon.
They were supposed to be the guardians of this Maltese falcon.
And I believe they're also the heirs to the Hospitalliers, you know, there was the kind
of Templars back in the day, sort of, you know, pre-13th century when they were, they
were disbanded, I guess, 14th century.
And then they were kind of the guardians of these pilgrims that would go to the Temple
Mount in, you know, Jerusalem.
And then the medic side of that was the Hospitalliers.
And so that sort of, there's some lineage between that and, you know, Knights of Malta.
But otherwise, I don't really understand.
What, you know, what they do.
I know they have sovereign status and they can kind of.
They do.
Yeah.
They're a military, they're a military order.
And they're, they're a sovereign, they're a sovereign military order.
And it's, it's, it's very clear that, you know, the guys like Reinhard Galen was in
the Knights, Knights of Malta.
He was a former Nazi.
Yeah.
Reinhard Galen is the guy that was the head of the anti-Soviet and anti-Eastern black intelligence
for the Third Reich.
And also became the director of intelligence for West Germany.
At the end of World War II, you know, at the behest of our OSS.
We got him put in there, you know, and Shackley worked directly with him, you know.
Yeah.
And, and, and also Otto Skorzeny.
Another former Nazi.
Yeah.
Otto Skorzeny, who ran the rat line, you know, smuggling them all out of there.
And they were Knights of Malta passports that were used.
Did you, I mean, you're Jesuit.
Did you ever use your Jesuit connections?
I was trying to figure out more about the Magenta crash, which was supposedly recovered.
You know, according to David Grush, it was recovered in Lombardy in 1933.
And I believe the Cardinal of Milan was also of Knight of Malta at the time.
And the UFO supposedly made itself to the Vatican where it was held for a while.
And then I think Pope Pius VI maybe then, you know, transferred it over to the US.
The 11th.
Pope Pius XI.
Okay.
Transferred it over to the US.
So do you know anything about that?
No.
No, I didn't actually.
It's interesting that...
Do you believe that's a real case or...?
It's interesting.
I didn't know about it.
Okay.
I didn't know about it until comparatively recently.
So that one never came across the radar.
Yeah.
So I had, I had been pretty well locked down on...
You gotta hit up your Vatican contacts.
Yeah.
Right.
Those that are still alive anyway.
You know, I mean, they're all dead.
I couldn't believe it.
I mean, virtually everybody that was there in the staff when I was there have all passed
away.
Damn.
It's totally bizarre.
Yeah.
But the bottom line is I didn't know about that one at all and no one has ever said anything
to me about it.
You know, and when I, when I talked to Johann Itz, who was the head of the Vatican archives,
you know, he's just always just smiled.
I mean, and...
Has he give you a smile, a smile of quiet knowing or...?
Oh yeah.
Okay.
He sent letters to them from Jesuit headquarters to ask for access for President Carter.
So he doesn't give you a befuddled laughing smile or something?
No, no, no.
Okay.
No.
It'd be perfectly easy for them to say, look, there's nothing to this.
You're crazy.
Okay.
No, but no, he knows, he knows that I know.
Interesting.
That his stuff is there.
And he just isn't going to let me have it.
So you, you were the lawyer for John Mack.
Yeah.
Who's the head of the Harvard psychiatry department and childhood friend of Bud Hopkins towards
the end of his career.
Yeah.
And he started to take very seriously these, uh, uh, experiencers.
People would experience abductions or alien contact and often it would come out in hypnotic
regression or through holotropic breathwork, which was one of his favorite kind of modalities.
And um, you have his final manuscript and he writes about, I heard at the end of his
life, he started to get into reptilians and was like interested in reptilians specifically.
I don't know.
Is there anything interesting in that final manuscript that, um, sort of shows his overall
worldview at the end of this, you know, decade plus long inquiry into the UFO alien question?
Yeah.
He, he, he really views the entire UFO ET issue as a, as a, as a window opening onto
the functioning of worldviews, you know, in, in, in our human family to really explain
an awful.
It had something to do with that because then that's what I was talking to him about.
He and I, but just before he got killed, we were planning on trying to set up a thing
called.
When you say he got killed, was that, do you think it was intentionally or accidentally?
No, it was actually.
It was an accident.
Yeah.
No.
In Europe.
Yeah.
I was on that within hours after it happened.
So sad.
Dug it out and knew who the guy was.
The guy's still in prison that, that ran him down.
He was just drunk and, uh, you know, yeah.
And, uh, so, so the, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh,
I, uh, that John and I were talking about the fact that this was a, uh, actually the
name of his manuscript is When Worldviews Collide.
And you know, the, Velikovsky, uh, uh, that, you know, from when worlds collide that's
what he does.
It's when world debate.
To play on that.
Yeah.
And the.
What was the Velikovsky?
What was the, When Worlds Collide, what was it about?
World's Collide is an old classic, uh.
Well.
Uh.
It's a translation of.
piece that velikovsky wrote it's a the theory that the asteroid belt uh is a another planet
that was here in our in our solar system uh and that it uh collided with the moon or something
i i just remember it and and that's right it's like the kyber belt or something yeah
the whole the whole asteroid belt is really that planet all blown up into into shrapnel basically
all through the asteroid belt and so mac was saying when world views collide like the kind
of western materialist reductionist worldview and the this world animistic worldview or something
one that encapsulated yes life beyond humans if you want to shatter the western mental structures
the the western mind so to speak which is now permeating the whole earth in its
materialist dualistic philosophy the way you do it is you take something
that's supposed to be in the spirit world because even in the west we can make allowance for the
spirit world and we can study it through mythology through religion through imagination through
poetry but the one unforgivable sin to the western mind is when something that should be
in the spirit world transgresses and shows up in the physical world that traffic is the cardinal
sin for the western mind so it has great power to shatter the belief structure of the western mind
and that's what's happening with the spirit world in the western mind so that's what's going to
happen and that's what's happening when that occurs and that's precisely what's occurring
in this subduction phenomenon and so he started really starting to perceive things
that because i i was some assistance in that because i i had you know done the master's degree
work and then started the phd work at harvard uh on that very issue uh trying to under trying to
understand things when you get a really complex issue what you want to do is figure out what the
kind of
front of just like a plane wreck, you know, you want to kind of reassemble the pieces that you
can recover and take a look at it. And what this does is it tends to shake down into this octave
of human worldviews, you know, that the, that only one aspect of which is their political
manifestation, you know, that, that, uh, runs from, from right to left, you know, from the
authoritarian to the reactionary, to the conservative, to the moderate, to the liberal,
to the progressive, to the utopianist, you know, that there's, there's a, there are integrated
worldviews that are internally self-referentially consistent, you know, and that they're all
predicated upon the answers that you provide to these four pillar questions about the origins of
the universe, the kind of end product, the teleological outcome of the universe is projected,
you know, what the ontological,
relationship between consciousness and the material manifestation, uh, of reality is the
big one. And the epistemological question is, you know, that what means do we have at our disposal
as human beings by means of which you can possibly answer questions like that? You know, are we
limited to our five senses or do we have other faculties? Do we have other kind of charisms that
we have access to that have been hidden or suppressed? You know, those are, those are the
fundamental questions.
Uh, those are the cosmic questions. And since we don't have the definitive answer to any of those
yet, uh, the way, as long, as long as you have a internally and self-referentially consistent
answer to all four of those questions, you have a worldview. It's a systematic worldview.
And if you can discern what the common principle is that makes all of them
similar to each other, the answers are consistent with each other. You apply that principle,
or any principle, to any question that you confront in making your judgments. And then
you have a philosophy. You apply one principle to any question you confront, and then you apply
a technique to address any past Sportsman makes questions you confront, and then you have a
philosophy. What a philosophy is is a consistent application of a
single principle that is generic to all four of these fundamental questions, if you can do
that. And that's what a philosophy is. And you have a sub component of that, your political
philosophy. And then you have a mode of spiritual expression, which is generic to that. That's where
you get these major issues, do you notice or not. You have a subject. You're not getting all, uh,
college, is there a topic, you're not getting into it then you concocting all these questions,
and then you have我们有役 начサイ, and we need whatever you call it, whatever, in terms of the academic motions,
world religions that are generic to a particular worldview you know and so i would i was starting
to explain all that to him that that i discovered you know when i actually went back to talk to john
rawls who's the head of the department of philosophy at harvard you know when i was running into these
conflicts that i was having with the different lawyers and the firms where i was you know they
all seem to be functioning on some different way so what did what did mac think you know when
what would happen when worldviews collided and when uh he he believes that that it's
absolutely clear that there's that the initial response that we have as human beings as homo
sapien to an encounter with an extraterrestrial being uh is that it it kind of shatters
uh the the kind of uh walls uh of the room uh the mansion of our
originally
worldview you know that all of a sudden the things are so completely different than anything you'd
ever assumed before that your world can fall apart as it were uh and so people and people
have this kind of cellular uh response when you find yourself actually confronted with an
extraterrestrial being that your whole cellular system reacts you know in a kind of a fight or
flight way uh that your subconscious doesn't have any control over it's just you just freak out
you know and and so but we so we started deciding that what we wanted to do is help train people
uh that had consistent repeated encounters you know because we found that to be a fairly common
theme that if you've been abducted once you've been usually abducted more than once right and
so that if it's going to happen again to try to train a person through holocaust
tropic breathing to kind of just calm themselves down and to get centered to try to get mastery over
that kind of cellular response that your body has because all of us that are alive right now
are the end of the chain of survivors i mean that's what's distinguished us you know that
that our our lineage have all survived yeah and gotten us through that's fascinating though he's
talking about almost like a manual for being physiologically ready for contact that's right
absolutely right
to try to overcome the cellular imprint that we have in us to react the allergic reaction yeah
and it is like if you're you know like the three body problem if you're in the dark forest
and you are afraid of making contact it's actually adaptive to sort of hide yourself
you would want to know that the other side is sort of receptive and stable and going to be okay yes
yeah you know when you when you uh appear oh that's right because if you uh you know cause this
oh they get they get in trouble i mean you know that karen one of the they used to throw things
out of her you know she's like you know she's like you know she's like you know she's like you know
she's like you know she's like you know she's like you know she's like you know she's like you know
i mean she'd throw lamps she was one of mac's patients she's wonderful that's cool yeah yeah
and then she was one of the first people who really got the the holotropic breathing training
so are you gonna release this book or what what do you what do you what are you planning on i haven't
i haven't ever he just gave it to me because he was getting set to go to england to do this
lecture on t.e lawrence and wanted me to go through it because it covers a lot of the
encounter we had with the the faculty committee yeah it's kind of his
his uh account of what what happened he was such an interesting guy well he won a pulitzer prize
for uh his book called the prince of disorder which is about prince of our disorder prince of
our disorder uh by about t.e lawrence he was lawrence of arabia yeah it was a psycho biography
right of lawrence who i believe was he was gay and he had been sort of sexually assaulted multiple
times and he had this sort of crazy and then he led this uprising you know and uh he's a pretty
fascinating character fast
fascinating character and mac himself was such a fascinating character yeah i feel like his search
for uh the ufo and alien question was kind of motivated by some autobiographical stuff with
his mother who i think did she die during childbirth or when he was very young no no
in fact his mother played this really kind of major role okay because he when when he first
got dragged up when he first started encountering uh these high-level military officials that were
in the military they were trying to get a psychiatric exam to try to deter them from
really pressing any further on this it was the first thing that would happen if they'd be ordered
to get a psychiatric exam because they'd seen an alien or something yeah because they wanted to file
a report they wanted to file a report about you know a a ufo encounter and they were always told
that you know you don't want to do this this is not good for your career did john mack was he kind
of abreast of any of the ufo stuff from his navy experience or no it came later no nothing no he was he was a complete
agnostic yeah you know to start with and then he got sent these like like uh arnie arnoldson who was
the the uh the actual commander of the the the mal uh the montana uh base you know the minute man
malmstrom uh that uh that he was the actual commander that filed the report with norrat about
it all uh and then they said are you are you trying to file a ufo report is that what you're doing and
yes he said it was the most important moment of his life he just said yes i am he says i'm not
letting this one go you know because they shut up they shut off 10 silos independent independently
wired nukes yeah minute men yeah yeah and so he was adamant that he was going to get that filed
in the and so you know that he and a number of other high ranking military people had been sent
to john mack at harvard as the head of the department of clinical psychiatry to do the
psychiatric workup on these guys
and after a half a dozen of these folks he started saying wait a second this doesn't make any sense
at all he said you know these are high-ranking military people there's lawyers and doctors
there's all kinds of people that are coming to report these things it doesn't make any sense and
so he started this actually kind of like a little investigation and he would train them to do the
holotropic breathing and get them calmed down and centered right and then he was asking them
questions okay now you're inside the craft look around and tell me what you're seeing and he was
giving little reports on these totally esoteric things you know that nobody would really make up
you know and and then he would see if other people saw similar stuff you know and he was verifying
that and so he started got to the point where he said wait a second there's there's something
really happening here with these people and so he called his mother about so she didn't die in job
so he called her uh and she said oh you want to you want to check with uh
with uh bud the hopkins kid you know that he's into this stuff you know even though he's a
sculptor and artist and all that kind of stuff but uh you know that uh our families are close and
you ought to he knows a lot about this and so that's how it happened is he ended up talking
to bud hopkins and hopkins said oh look let me show you you know and he started giving him a
lot more people and so by the time he contacted me you know he he'd interviewed like 100 people wow
you know uh who'd had these experiences and so that uh and so he ended up calling me and uh when
he got confronted by this faculty committee and they called me and asked me if i would legally
represent him uh and so i went there to and confronted the the faculty committee you know
and but very fortunately went with john to meet with lawrence rockefeller and lawrence rockefeller
you know told us all about you know his best friend seeing a ufm
that's why he was convinced it was true yeah lawrence rockefeller was a patron for a lot of
early ufo research he funded john mack yep he funded stephen greer uh i think whitley stryber
has told me a story about meeting with lawrence rockefeller in wyoming and the tetons at his ranch
or whatever why do you think lawrence rockefeller was so interested in the subject so you mentioned
that his friend had an experience that's interesting whitley is the prince of lichtenstein
hans adams whoever it was that's all i know about lawrence rockefeller and lawrence rockefeller
he's apparently extremely interested in ufos he was his best friend i think he thinks that
jesus is going to come down on a saucer or something it's like some eschatological worldview
i don't i didn't know he gathered the guy named john brandenburg who i interviewed said that uh
prince hans adams um had uh gathered all of the uh roswell uh witnesses
i think in the 70s or something or the 80s i don't know what you know and uh
that he wanted to speak to all of them and kind of you know uh yeah understand what had happened
oh yeah so he was very interested in this well that in in told us that you know because he said
that's why he was so convinced that it was true that his friend who was the prince of lichtenstein
had seen one uh and that uh had actually walked right up onto one you know that was in that was
up in the mountains very similar to a to a an experience of one of the guys that i knew you know
the the son of uh
uh bill todman you know mark goodson and bill todman mark goodson and bill todman were the guys
that used to produce i love lucy and the 64 000 question and that tune all those kind of quizzy
shows kind of things back in the 50s and made millions you know and uh and uh i was out i was
out at the we were uh mace neufeld and bob ramey had contacted me the guy to do all the tom clancy
yeah yeah they wanted to do the iran con
contra movie uh-huh and so they they contacted me to talk with them down and down in l.a and i
was down in the office with uh bob ramey the who was the president of the academy of arts and
science he's the head of the oscars thing you know and uh so we were talking with him and his
his uh executive uh his exec uh uh uh his name uh uh i forgot his name but anyway that that he
contacts me uh in the
and said uh he said look there's a friend of mine that wants to talk to you the you know would you
he told me not to say who he is but would you trust me to to uh take you there to him so i said
okay we'll do that so so we went out and uh what was the guy's name anyway we go out get into this
big red cadillac convertible and we drive off into uh warner brothers and we go over to the
warner brothers lot and we go in and it turns out that it's
uh bill todman's son of mark goodson and bill todman so here's his son who's now uh uh a an
exec in warner brothers you know and uh and he wanted to tell me about an experience that he had
had and that he had uh he was uh in college and he was on summer break and he was in the tetons
outside of boulder and he was climbing in the tetons and he came up into this meadow
and there was a ufo just sitting right
hovering right there in the meadow and he walked all the way over to it and and put his hand on it
he said and it was like alive he said this is alive this thing you know and then the whole
thing started kind of shuddering and and raised up so he backed away from it and just went went
and shot away and he wouldn't he didn't dare tell anybody because he thought that they would ruin
his whole reputation and stuff in the industry uh but uh it turns out that he said that his father
senior or bill todman senior uh was uh best friends with uh uh he's this big famous
uh author that uh writes these romance novels anyway that uh uh and he wrote he wrote a book
about it uh partly because bill todman jr told him that he'd had this experience he
wrote a thing called the doomsday the doomsday uh doomsday plan or something
who's the author um sydney sheldon his name was and he wrote like 50 of these you know
books you know made millions of dollars he too wouldn't dare ever be public about it
so he wrote this book called the doomsday project you know a a hypothetical of a of a
saucer that had crashed uh in a tour bus over in italy or somewhere it happened to be driving
by when they were doing a recovery of it and so this young lieutenant colonel in the
naval intelligence was assigned to find out where all the people were that were on the bus that saw
this because they uh just wanted to explain to them that this was just an experimental
uh thing you know so that they wouldn't be distressed well it turns out they all started
getting killed all these witnesses and uh and and so uh sydney sheldon wrote this book
about it and it's the only time he ever said anything about it and then went right back to
his normal life wow and so uh so bill todman jr wanted me to know about this just to tell me
and so i've been constantly trying to get him over the years said why don't you
go public yeah you got more money than the pope you know now from your inheritance why don't you
you want to do it he still hasn't agreed to do anything well you've done it for him now
but yeah because he was perfectly honest about it i didn't have any doubt that it was
sure sure yeah well he's a real nice guy yeah but it still hasn't done anything
danny it's exciting times right now do you have a prediction for the next uh
three months of disclosure and the ufo truth some of it's easy so you know the the the the
senate bill is going to get repassed you know at all 64 pages exactly the same as the senator round
it's it's rounds is going to south dakota yeah from south dakota he's going to sponsor it uh and
that uh that uh that uh uh the the uh schumer will co-sponsor it uh we don't we don't we don't have
uh uh marco around anymore rubio rubio to sponsor but but you know we're hoping to try to get state
department in on this okay because there's this whole state department dimension that is totally
inappropriate for the state department not to have been brought in on this i mean you're dealing with
an entire foreign power here
uh in the they're being x'd out so i mean now that rubio's over there you know he ought to
yeah he's very interested in on record on you know this whole topic and sure he is um yeah one of his
aides was probably as deep as it gets on the topic as well and was sort of you know i think encountered
a bunch of obstacles as a result of his involvement yeah yeah so so the bottom line is they're gonna
they're gonna the senate is gonna pass the the 64-page bill again uh probably around the middle
of july
between july 15th 20th or so that they'll they'll pass it and they'll send it on over the house
you know we're we're focusing on crenshaw crenshaw you know dan crenshaw is now the new head of the
intelligence committee in the house and that's where we ran into trouble before it was primarily
mike turner who was the the uh congressman from ohio right part wright patterson uh district
you know it was it was stopping the the full bill from being passed as crenshaw
pro ufo and transparency we don't know yet we're trying to get but he's he's uh he's certainly not
uh anywhere near as bad as turner was you know turner had his own
personal agenda because of his constituency there you know with the with the base but
but crenshaw's a a guy that's you know been critical of things he doesn't agree with he's
he's kind of a bit of a maverick uh and he's got a lot of integrity you know tough guy you know you're
it's a is a seal team dude you know but uh but eye patch yeah yeah yeah but he's not he's not
just kind of a knee-jerk reactionary yeah you know so he's there's a real promise there and so we're
going to be meeting with him and his staff to try to get him to see if he can give a leadership in
the intelligence committee to green light the full bill you know or at least a lot more of it
we've gotten 23 pages of the 64 passed with unfortunately some amendments even that part
yeah but but the bottom line what we're after is the appointment of the board that we we want to
get that portion of the 64 page bill done at least this time around is to get the get the the the
panel uh appointed you know now one of the challenges is that well our new paradigm
institute is one of the groups that's authorized to to make
recommendations uh under the statute uh but the president is the one ultimately decides who's
going to who he's going to appoint the congress can mandate that he do it they can pass the
statute and say the president is to appoint this board you know but then he could you know he could
appoint his daughter you know to be on it or whatever he wants to do and so we're we're going
to try to appoint we're trying to recommend uh a group that is
that is sort of almost beyond uh beyond criticism you know the kind of the kind of people you'd
really want to have there uh and then hope that that will cause trump to say okay good that's a
good group let's have them do it uh so we're hoping this year or at least this side of the
next election this side of the election in 2026 to get an additional chunk of the 64-page bill passed
um and then you know it's going to be a dynamic going on with this board you know
it's going to be a Public Health Act with the part having to do with the with the
board okay and we're going to have you know it's going to be a dynamic going on
with this board there are going to be a lot of people inside the national security infrastructure
that are going to have people in there that are going to continue to keep it as sphinctered
as possible uh you know uh and then there's going to be lots of people putting pressure on us right to have it be
reveal everything right now just dump it on everybody you know that's so there's there
there are extremes all around us here but what we're trying to do is kind of navigate our way
through to to really the the dynamic that's going to take place hopefully uh between now and
november of 2026 you know uh now we've got the we've got the uh end of september coming here
in 2025 when that's the extension that the the uh national archives has given to the military
services and the intelligence community to to gather together all the information they've got
okay and that that's in that's a standing order that they've got you know it's still got that
wiggle language in there saying in there to turn it over to the national archives as soon as
possible you know the the senate bill said immediately
you
and they gave them the drop dead date of october 20th you know and now they've managed to get the
house to water it down say as soon as possible so my sense is their lawyers are going to push
back against us but so i'm not i'm not i i don't give it more than a 51 chance you know that we're
going to get any kind of meaningful release of that information yeah and at the end of september
well danny you're doing the lord's work and uh godspeed i'm excited to see what what happens
uh
in the next few months and years and uh you're you're really important champion for this whole
topic and i hope that uh you know as as much as i love you know my own podcast i hope that you
go on like tucker carlson or joe rogan or something and uh the jf the jfk thing is so
important and i know both are so interested in it and i i didn't you know i i dabble and like
you know i've i've learned you know from oliver stone and you know red uh you know mark lane and
and jim mars and all these guys and like i think you're the best living um reteller of the entire
story in a way that is a coherent narrative with all the players but you also talk about motives
and yeah so i think uh it would be great if you um if that was amplified as much as possible no
i'd be happy to do it you know i did the you know no no interview is any better than the interviewer
uh-huh uh-huh that's true that's true well i think they're both great but i mean they're
more importantly than that if they have much bigger platforms than me i mean i have a big
platform but there's their next level so biggest in the world yeah they both seem to be sincerely
interested you know and so that's the key you know and they're not particularly biased or
prejudiced in any way about it no and and be and because they they straddle different kind of
worldviews you know and reach out to people that are adherence to different worldviews it's a
valuable forum yeah those
both of those guys yeah well danny it's an honor man appreciate you taking the time this is always
awesome yeah always learned so much